Hello, everybody, and welcome to our second drink of Launch Party Part 2. This is a very fun episode, and we have some really great behind-the-scenes stories from the pizza delivery guy who was played by Kevin McHale, and writer Jen Salada gave us her theory on where Andy got that ice sculpture, plus a lot of other fun tidbits. I just loved hearing from both of them. Yeah, me too. Well, I want to share about this fun runner where everyone is reacting to not being invited to New York's fancy corporate launch party. I wanted to read two candy bag alts because they are hilarious and we learn a little something new about Creed and Phyllis. Here's Creed's. Quote, I don't care about the party, really. I just don't like being left out.
大家好，欢迎收听我们《办公室派对（下）》的第二杯特饮。这一集非常有趣，我们从凯文·麦克海尔饰演的披萨外卖员那里得到了一些很棒的幕后故事，编剧简·萨拉达也分享了她关于安迪从哪里弄来那个冰雕的理论，还有很多其他有趣的细节。我真的很喜欢听他们两位的分享。我也是。嗯，我想分享一个有趣的连贯情节，就是大家对没被邀请参加纽约那场豪华公司发布会派对的反应。我想读两段糖果袋里的备选台词，因为它们太搞笑了，而且我们还了解到了关于克里德和菲利斯的一些新东西。这是克里德的。引用：“我不在乎派对，真的。我只是不喜欢被排除在外。”
Middle child syndrome, I guess. I'm number seven of 14. Oh my goodness. That's such a big share. I know. He's a middle child of 14. All right. Here were two that Phyllis said. Quote, it's a good thing I wasn't invited. Tonight is intimate massage night with Bob Vance. Oh. Okay, Phyllis. Well, lady, guess who else went into the candy bag alts for this one? It's me.
我想是中间孩子综合症吧。我在14个孩子里排第七。天哪。这分享的信息量好大。我知道。他是14个孩子里的中间那个。好了。这是菲利斯说的两句。引用：“没被邀请真是太好了。今晚是和鲍勃·万斯的亲密按摩之夜。”哦。好吧，菲利斯。那么，女士，猜猜还有谁也进了这一集的糖果袋备选台词？是我。
And I found another michael mangled phrase moment. This is when he's talking about not being invited to the fancy New York party, and here is what he says. The thing that I admire most about this branch is its resilience. Resilis instances. Resilability to bounce back. Being uninvited from Ryan's New York Party heard us all a bit initially, but I know this group. We're not going to let us get this down. Because they have resilability? They have resilability. Yeah. Someone, if that had made it into an episode, someone would have heard it and thought it
我还发现了另一个迈克尔口误的瞬间。这是他在谈论没被邀请参加纽约豪华派对时说的。这是他说的：“我最钦佩这个分部的一点就是它的韧性。韧性实例。韧性能力（resilability）来反弹。没被邀请参加瑞恩的纽约派对起初确实让我们都受了点伤，但我了解这个团队。我们不会让这事打倒我们。因为他们有韧性能力？”他们有韧性能力。是的。如果这被剪进正片里，肯定有人会听了之后以为
was a word. Yeah. Resilability. Resilability. Okay. Well, there's also a deleted scene I need to discuss with you in particular. Okay. Do you as Pam remember blowing up balloons for this episode? Yes, I do. Yes, I do. Because there is a whole scene where Angela has put Pam to work. You know, she's in charge of the party planning committee,
那是个词。是的。韧性能力。韧性能力。好吧。嗯，还有个删减片段我需要和你特别讨论一下。好的。作为帕姆，你还记得这一集里吹气球的事吗？记得，我记得。是的，我记得。因为有一整段戏是安吉拉让帕姆去干活。你知道，她是派对策划委员会的负责人，
and she's making Pam blow up balloons, and then Jim comes up and starts talking to her, and we learn a little something new about Stanley. Let's hear this clip. What is going? Yeah, I'm here. Angela needs me to blow up 50 balloons and find a famous person. Stanley was an extra in Philadelphia, so just ask him.
她让帕姆吹气球，然后吉姆走过来开始和她说话，我们了解到了关于斯坦利的一些新情况。让我们听听这段剪辑。怎么了？是的，我在这儿。安吉拉需要我吹50个气球，还要找个名人。斯坦利在费城当过临时演员，所以去问问他吧。
Really? Mm-hmm. That would be fun for everyone. I think so. Stanley. What? Oh, yeah, so you're going to want to go through his agent. Okay.
真的吗？嗯哼。那对大家来说会很有趣。我也这么觉得。斯坦利。什么？哦，是的，所以你要通过他的经纪人去联系。好的。
I get very dusty about that stuff. Right. Lady, I want to thank you for unearthing this scene. Mm-hmm. I got so lightheaded blowing up those balloons, because as you can hear, It begins with me blowing up balloons. And this reminds me of when I was on splitting up together, and I stayed for like five hours while they put like a bald cap on my head,
我对那些事情非常谨慎。没错。女士，我要感谢你发掘出这段戏。嗯哼。吹那些气球吹得我头晕眼花，因为正如你所听到的，开头就是我在吹气球。这让我想起我拍《分分合合》的时候，我待了大概五个小时，他们往我头上套了个秃头套，
and we filmed a whole dream sequence, and then they cut it. Oh, my gosh. Well, that sound you hear of the balloon being blown up is you. They don't cut away. So you had to blow up a balloon at the top of the scene every time you guys did it. Correct. Well, Angela, I also found my table draft of this episode. This is what we read at the table read.
我们拍了一整段梦境戏，结果被剪掉了。天哪。嗯，你听到的那个吹气球的声音就是你。他们没有切掉。所以你们每次拍的时候，你都得在戏的开头吹一个气球。没错。好吧，安吉拉，我还找到了这一集的剧本草稿。这是我们在剧本围读会上读的内容。
and do you remember how you have that great talking head? Oh, my gosh, it's one of my favorite talking heads. It speaks to me so deeply when you say, plan a party, Angela. Oh, and the entire world will see it. Oh, and here's $65 for your budget. Oh, and here's four idiots who will do nothing but weigh you down. Oh, and your cat's still dead. Yeah, that was one of my favorites. That's one of my favorites. Well, you also had a few others, and I want to read you one that cracked me up. You had extra in the table draft. Here was one. You were going to say, I constantly have to want up myself. I'm my biggest critic, my own worst enemy, and the only shoulder I have around here to cry on, let's party.
你还记得你有那个很棒的独白吗？天哪，那是我最喜欢的独白之一。当你这么说的时候，它深深地触动了我：“策划一场派对，安吉拉。哦，全世界都会看到的。哦，这是给你的65美元预算。哦，这是四个除了拖你后腿什么都不会的白痴。哦，你的猫还是死的。”是的，那是我的最爱之一。那也是我的最爱之一。嗯，你还有几个其他的，我想读一个让我笑喷的。你在剧本草稿里还有额外的台词。这是其中一个。你本来要说：“我必须不断地超越自己。我是自己最大的批评者，自己最大的敌人，也是这里唯一能让我依靠哭泣的肩膀，派对开始吧。”
I tried to channel my inter-angelo. That's really fun. Oh, I love it. Okay, lastly, we have a few cat lovers here on Office Ladies, and we all love a good cat meme. And so does fellow cat lover Patrice R from Delaware, who wrote in to say, Ladies, did you see the LOL cat for this episode? What's an LOL cat? I had no idea what an LOL cat was, or is it a lull cat?
我试着引导我内心的安吉拉。那真的很有趣。哦，我喜欢它。好的，最后，我们《办公室女士》这里有几位爱猫人士，我们都喜欢好的猫咪表情包。特拉华州的猫友帕特里斯·R也写信来说：“女士们，你们看到这一集的LOL猫了吗？什么是LOL猫？”我根本不知道什么是LOL猫，还是叫“lull cat”？
I don't know if I'm even saying it right, but I looked it up on the internet. Well, I guess an LOL cat, according to the internet, is an image of one or more cats, intentionally and grammatically speaking incorrectly. It's known as like LOL speak. Okay. A fan made one for this episode. You remember when Kevin says this about the pizza? Oh, no, it's bad. It's real bad. It's like eating a hot circle of garbage.
我不知道我读得对不对，但我上网查了一下。嗯，我想根据互联网的说法，LOL猫是一张或多张猫的照片，故意在语法上拼写错误。这被称为“LOL语”。好的。有个粉丝为这一集做了一个。你还记得凯文说关于披萨的那段话吗？“哦不，太糟糕了。真的很糟糕。就像在吃一个热的垃圾圆圈。”
Well, I guess someone made an LOL cat meme from that phrase. It even ended up on the office tally website. Here's the thing. I looked at the picture closely. It's a little chihuahua. Wait, I guess dogs can be in these memes. So it doesn't even have to be a cat? I guess not. But here, I have a picture of it. I'll share it in one of our Friday shoutouts. So here's the chihuahua. He's got a big piece of pizza in his mouth. And it says, as like eaten hot circle of garbage. I mean, this is, this is so crazy. I'm learning so much. So we were an LOL cat this week. I looked online. There's tons and tons of these animals saying little office clips. Well, that is delightful. I'm going to go look these up. I'd like to see little memes of cats and chihuahuas. They're really cute. All right, everybody.
嗯，我想有人用那句话做了一个LOL猫表情包。它甚至最终出现在了《办公室》的统计网站上。问题是，我仔细看了那张照片。那是一只小吉娃娃。等等，我想狗也可以出现在这些表情包里。所以甚至不需要是猫？我想不是。但这里，我有一张照片。我会在我们周五的致谢环节分享它。所以这是那只吉娃娃。他嘴里叼着一大块披萨。上面写着：“就像吃了一个热的垃圾圆圈。”我的意思是，这太疯狂了。我学到了很多。所以我们这周成了一只LOL猫。我上网看了看。有成吨成吨的动物在说《办公室》的小片段。嗯，那太令人愉快了。我要去搜来看看。我想看猫和吉娃娃的小表情包。它们真的很可爱。好了，各位。
Thanks so much. And now here's our second drink of launch party part two. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hey, gang. Hey, everybody. We are here this week to finish talking about launch party.
非常感谢。现在是我们的《办公室派对（下）》第二杯特饮。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你做终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。嘿，伙计们。嘿，大家好。我们这周在这里完成关于《办公室派对》的讨论。
It's launch party part two. And it is a launch party of the Dunder Mifflin Infinity website. It's a big deal. Jinks! Buy me a Coke. It's season four, episode six, written by Jen Salada and directed by Ken Whittingham. Here is a summary. Do it.
这是《办公室派对（下）》。这是邓德·米夫林无限网站的发布会派对。这可是件大事。心有灵犀！请我喝可乐。这是第四季第六集，由简·萨拉达编剧，肯·惠廷汉执导。这是剧情摘要。开始吧。
This week, Michael returns to Scranton after realizing he was not invited to the big New York launch party for Dunder Mifflin Infinity, but instead he has to celebrate via webcam. So he decides to ramp up the launch party in Scranton and he gives Angela a very long list of demands. Then he orders pizza. But when the pizza delivery guy refuses to honor. Michael's half-off coupon, he holds him hostage in the conference room. Meanwhile, Andy tries to woo Angela to the dismay of Dwight. Does he? He's relentless. And a little charming. And a little charming and a little douchey. We'll get there. All right. Fast fact number one, we have a big guest star alert. Yes, we're so excited, you guys. The pizza delivery guy was played by Kevin McHale.
这周，迈克尔在意识到自己没被邀请参加邓德·米夫林无限在纽约举办的大型发布会派对后回到了斯克兰顿，但他不得不通过网络摄像头庆祝。所以他决定在斯克兰顿加大发布会派对的力度，并给了安吉拉一份很长的需求清单。然后他点了披萨。但当披萨外卖员拒绝兑现迈克尔的半价优惠券时，他把对方扣押在会议室里。与此同时，安迪试图追求安吉拉，这让德怀特感到沮丧。他真的这么做了吗？他锲而不舍。而且有点迷人。而且有点迷人，还有点讨厌。我们稍后会讲到。好了，第一个速记事实，我们有个大客串明星预警。是的，我们太兴奋了，伙计们。披萨外卖员由凯文·麦克海尔饰演。
Now, you guys probably know Kevin because he would go on to be a regular on the TV show Glee. But this was about two years before that happened. This appearance on the office was one of his first television acting jobs. So we reached out to him to hear how it all went down. Yeah. Kevin, thanks for letting me slide into your DMs. Angela really slid into his DMs guys. Hey, I always feel so weird, but he's a very nice person.
现在，你们可能认识凯文，因为他后来成了电视剧《欢乐合唱团》的常驻演员。但这发生在那之前大约两年。这次在《办公室》的客串是他最早的电视表演工作之一。所以我们联系了他，想听听当时的情况。是的。凯文，谢谢你让我滑进你的私信。安吉拉真的滑进了他的私信，伙计们。嘿，我总是觉得很奇怪，但他是个非常好的人。
I was like, hey, Angela and Jenna here. Hello. And he was wonderful. He sent us in audio clips. And here is what he had to say, you guys, about coming in to audition for the role. It's so charming. Sam, can you play that clip? So what I remember about the audition is actually the callback because the initial audition, no memory, but the callback, I was waiting in the stairwell. It was me and Dave Franco and a couple other guys and then one of the casting assistants comes out and says oh we're going to start in a few minutes but we just have to wait for Steve and I'm someone who has terrible terrible nerves and I don't know if my manager didn't know and didn't tell me but I was very unaware that Steve Carell was going
我说：“嘿，我是安吉拉和珍娜。”你好。他太棒了。他给我们发了音频剪辑。这是他关于来试镜这个角色的说法，伙计们。太迷人了。萨姆，你能播放那个剪辑吗？“关于试镜，我记得的其实是复试，因为最初的试镜我一点记忆都没有，但复试时，我正在楼梯间等着。当时有我和戴夫·弗兰科还有其他几个家伙，然后其中一个选角助理出来说：‘哦，我们要几分钟后开始，但我们得等史蒂夫。’我是一个非常非常紧张的人，我不知道我的经纪人是不是不知道没告诉我，但我完全不知道史蒂夫·卡瑞尔会
to read with us for the callback and I went in I sat there and tried with all my might just to get the words out. And at some point, Steve Carell, like, chuckled, looked at the casting director and they chuckled. And I was like, oh, my God, I made him laugh. And that was it. Like, I, if I didn't get the job, I was happy enough just with that, that I made he and Alison Jones laugh. By the way, Alison Jones is the casting director. She was the first casting director to just continuously give me a chance when I hadn't worked or booked anything and she kept getting me further and further along of these jobs like this or super bad and she just kept putting me in the room and I have her to thank for giving me any confidence to even continue to
来和我们一起读剧本进行复试，我进去坐在那儿，尽我所能把台词说出来。在某个时刻，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔笑了笑，看了看选角导演，他们都笑了。我当时想：‘哦，天哪，我让他笑了。’就是这样。就像，如果我没得到这份工作，光是能让他和艾莉森·琼斯笑，我就已经足够开心了。顺便说一下，艾莉森·琼斯是选角导演。她是第一个在我还没工作或没接到任何角色时就不断给我机会的选角导演，她让我在这类工作或《太坏了》中走得越来越远，她一直把我放在那个房间里，我要感谢她给了我任何继续
pursue acting at all. That's Allison Jones. Yeah and then also Steve just so gracious coming there for those callbacks and being there in the scene with him like that. I mean, I just loved that story. But I see why they asked Steve to pop in on this audition because the pizza delivery guy, it's all him and Steve and Rain. Yeah. And Steve was a big star. And the last thing you want to do is hire someone and bring them to set and then they freeze up
追求表演的信心。”那是艾莉森·琼斯。是的，还有史蒂夫，他来参加那些复试并和他在戏里搭档真是太亲切了。我的意思是，我太喜欢那个故事了。但我明白为什么他们请史蒂夫来参加这次试镜，因为披萨外卖员的戏份全是他、史蒂夫和雷恩的。是的。而且史蒂夫是个大明星。你最不想做的事就是雇佣某人并带他们到片场，然后他们僵住了，
because they're now performing not with a casting associate, but with this big star. So he did. it. He made it through and he got the job. Yeah, I like when he said I was just concentrating on getting the words out. Well, he does a great, great job in this part. And guys, he sent in a few other audio clips that will sprinkle in throughout the episode. Yeah. All right. So what's your fast fact number two? Okay. My fast fact number two, Ang, when I was researching this episode, I was going through my archives and all this stuff started popping up from the 2007 Emmy Awards. Yes. Oh, that was a fun one. Yes. We shot this episode right around the same time as the Emmys. And this was the year that I was
因为他们现在不是在和选角助理演戏，而是在和这位大明星演戏。所以他做到了。他坚持了下来并得到了这份工作。是的，我喜欢他说“我只是专注于把台词说出来”。嗯，他在这个角色里做得非常非常棒。伙计们，他还发来了一些其他的音频剪辑，我们会在这一集里穿插播放。是的。好了，你的第二个速记事实是什么？好的。我的第二个速记事实，安吉，当我研究这一集时，我正在翻阅我的档案，所有这些东西都从2007年艾美奖中冒了出来。是的。哦，那真是有趣的一次。是的。我们拍摄这一集的时间就在艾美奖前后。那一年我
nominated. I know. It was a big deal. We were so excited. It was so cool. And I found a blog that I wrote on MySpace about getting the nomination. And it's so cute. I got to hear the old. Ye oldie MySpace blog. Let's hear it. Here's what I wrote. Man, I am so excited. I just can't tell you what this means to me. Not because it is an award or something like that,
被提名了。我知道。那可是件大事。我们太兴奋了。太酷了。我发现了一篇我在MySpace上写的关于获得提名的博客。太可爱了。我得听听旧的。古老的MySpace博客。让我们听听。这是我写的：“天哪，我太兴奋了。我无法告诉你这对意味着什么。不是因为它是一个奖项之类的东西，
but because it feels like it's for our gal Pam. She's a shy girl who doesn't get recognized very often, you know? It's like that shot from the episode with the art show where Pam is standing in front of her display, waiting for the first visitor to come by. That just sums it all up for me. So I guess I feel it in that part of me that is Pam. The part that still gets excited to show my art and no people are responding to it.
而是因为它感觉像是为了我们的帕姆。她是一个不常被认可的害羞女孩，你知道吗？就像艺术展那一集里帕姆站在她的展示品前，等待第一个参观者到来的那个镜头。那对我来说总结了一切。所以我猜我在帕姆的那一部分感受到了它。那部分仍然为展示我的艺术而感到兴奋，并且知道人们正在回应它。”
It's like, hey, people showed up to my art show. Aw, that is so sweet, Jenna. And you know what? I remember I did not win the Emmy. And I remember thinking like, damn it, I wanted Pam to go up there and get her trophy. It was like her Dundee's moment. I really wanted to say, I feel God in this. this Emmys tonight. I know. You were so excited. You had your opening line. It was going to crush.
就像，“嘿，人们来看我的艺术展了。”噢，那太甜了，珍娜。你知道吗？我记得我没赢得艾美奖。我记得当时想：“该死，我真想让帕姆上去拿她的奖杯。”那就像她的邓迪奖时刻。我真的很想说：“我在这届艾美奖上感受到了上帝。”我知道。你太兴奋了。你有你的开场白。那本来会很轰动的。
You would have crushed it. I would have crushed it. But lady, you were my plus one. I know. I was about to say, I remember this year because you had a really hot date. It was me. We got to go together and it was a blast. But it was also, if you remember, Angela, it was in the round. I will never forget it. It was so bizarre. So, You know, normally the Emmys, it's like in a traditional type theater where you sit in theater-style seating, right? One row in front of the other. Well, this year, it's like the Television Academy decided to mix it up. And they put the seats in a circle, and the stage in the middle, a big circle.
你本来会轰动的。我会轰动的。但女士，你是我的加一。我知道。我正要说，我记得那一年，因为你有一个非常火辣的约会对象。那就是我。我们能一起去，真是太棒了。但如果你还记得的话，安吉拉，那是在圆形的场地里。我永远不会忘记。太离奇了。所以，你知道，通常艾美奖是在传统的剧院里，你坐在剧院式的座位上，对吧？一排排在另一排前面。嗯，那一年，电视学院决定换个花样。他们把座位排成一个圆圈，舞台在中间，一个大圆圈。
So it was like theater in the round. And Jenna, I remember where we were seated. Oh, I knew the minute we took our seats, I wasn't going to win. Oh, honey. we were in the back of the circle so we faced everyone's butt all night all night we just saw real fancy people's asses that's what we saw and we kept thinking at some point are they going to turn around and face our section no never once the entire thing was performed as if there were not people sitting behind the speaker it was so bizarre and you know sometimes someone who would win
所以就像圆形剧场。珍娜，我记得我们坐在哪里。哦，我们坐下的那一刻我就知道我不会赢了。哦，亲爱的。我们在圆圈的后面，所以我们整晚都对着每个人的屁股。整晚我们看到的都是那些大人物的屁股，我们看到的就是那个。我们一直想，在某个时刻，他们会转过身来面对我们这一区吗？不，从来没有。整个过程的表演就好像演讲者后面没有坐人一样。太离奇了，你知道，有时获奖的人
would like sort of glance over their shoulder like, hey, guys, how are you back there? And we would get so excited. We're like, we're good. We're good. Hi. But yeah, it just was an evening of fancy TV butts. That's what. Yeah.
会稍微回头看一眼，好像在说：“嘿，伙计们，你们在后面怎么样？”我们就会变得非常兴奋。我们说：“我们很好。我们很好。嗨。”但是的，那只是一个充满高级电视屁股的夜晚。就是这样。是的。
It was very funny. But something else I noticed when I was seeing all these photos pop up from this time, Angela, was that my back was still not healed at the time. And there were a lot of restrictions on what I was allowed to wear, not wear. I couldn't wear anything that was too. tight on my rib cage, too tight on my waist, and I could not wear high heels. So I have all these pictures of us on different red carpets. Yeah. Going to the various, you know, pre-emments, events and things where I'm wearing these baggy dresses and like bejeweled flip-flops. Yes. Yes. And I mean,
那非常有趣。但当我看到所有这些照片从那个时候冒出来时，我还注意到一件事，安吉拉，那就是我的背当时还没好。我对能穿什么、不能穿什么有很多限制。我不能穿任何在肋骨上太紧、腰部太紧的衣服，而且我不能穿高跟鞋。所以我有很多我们在不同红毯上的照片。是的。去参加各种，你知道，艾美奖前的活动和事情，我穿着这些宽松的裙子和镶满珠宝的人字拖。是的。是的。我的意思是，
I just felt like in that moment, you were like family for me because my sisters love a bejeweled flip-flop. They love it. Yeah, I wore bejeweled flip-flops to the 2007 Emmy Awards. And you got to look at people's butts. There you go. It was a special time. I was really bummed you didn't win, though. And I have no poker face.
在那一刻，我觉得你就像我的家人，因为我的姐妹们喜欢镶满珠宝的人字拖。她们喜欢它。是的，我穿着镶满珠宝的人字拖参加了2007年艾美奖。而你得盯着人们的屁股看。就是这样。那是一段特别的时光。不过你没赢我真的很沮丧。而且我没有扑克脸。
It's like when Steve didn't win year after year, you know, it's a good thing the camera's not on me are whips away fast because it's all across my face. It's what that? You know, they really. missed an opportunity for some good television by not having the camera on you every time one of us lost. Oh, yeah. That's the before the day of like the memes. My face would have been a meme. For sure. For sure. All right, lady, well, I'm going to move us on to fast fact number three because I've got a great big surprise for you. I know. You've been a little bragy about this and text to me leading up. She's like, just wait for fast fact number three. I'm like, okay, what is it?
就像史蒂夫年复一年没赢的时候，你知道，幸好摄像机没对着我，否则我肯定会立刻表现出来，因为全写在我的脸上。那是怎么回事？你知道，他们真的错过了一些好的电视机会，因为没有在每次我们中有人输的时候把摄像机对准你。哦，是的。那是表情包时代之前。我的脸肯定会成为一个表情包。肯定的。肯定的。好了，女士，我要带我们进入第三个速记事实，因为我有一个大大的惊喜给你。我知道。你在这件事上有点炫耀，之前还给我发短信。她说：“等着瞧第三个速记事实。”我说：“好吧，是什么？”
I got the deep dive on Pam's plants. Shut up. Shut up! I know everything about Pam's plants and who's responsible for them. Oh my gosh, I have to tell you, I was texting with Jen Salada last night, and Jen texted me, she said, Angie, I didn't even know that Pam had a plant at front reception until I started listening to your podcast. I need to know all of this.
我深入挖掘了帕姆的植物。闭嘴。闭嘴！我知道关于帕姆植物的一切，以及谁负责它们。天哪，我必须告诉你，我昨晚在和简·萨拉达发短信，简给我发短信说：“安吉，我甚至不知道帕姆在前台有植物，直到我开始听你们的播客。我需要知道这一切。”
What, what, what, what? Tell me. all right i reached out to our set designer michael gallenberg yes who told me it was steve du scherer the lead set dresser yes who was in charge of pam's plants i had a feeling it would be him because he sort of like set that whole area every day yes well i called steve you did angela yes we had the best conversation oh so i remembered steve mainly as the guy who was always having to deal with our computers. Yes, he would come.
什么，什么，什么，什么？告诉我。好吧，我联系了我们的布景设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格，是的，他告诉我那是史蒂夫·杜舍尔，首席布景师，是的，他负责帕姆的植物。我有一种预感会是他，因为他每天都会布置那个区域。是的，好吧，我给史蒂夫打了电话。你打了，安吉拉？是的，我们进行了最好的谈话。哦，所以我主要记得史蒂夫是那个总是要处理我们电脑的人。是的，他会来。
And also like if our lamps went out or just sort of like all the things on our desk that needed attention. Yeah. Well, I told Steve that because he said, Jenna, do you remember me? And I said, yes, Steve, my memory of you is that you were always crouching under my desk dealing with my computer. And he laughed so hard. He said, well, that was probably 80% of my jaw. was just dealing with all of the computers at your desk. He said he was the one that was in charge of finally setting up the speaker on Oscars desk.
还有，比如如果我们的灯坏了，或者只是桌子上所有需要注意的东西。是的。好吧，我告诉了史蒂夫，因为他说：“珍娜，你还记得我吗？”我说：“是的，史蒂夫，我对你的记忆就是你总是蹲在我的桌子底下处理我的电脑。”他笑得很大声。他说：“嗯，那可能是我80%的工作。就是处理你桌子上所有的电脑。”他说他是那个最终负责在奥斯卡的桌子上设置扬声器的人。
You remember? Yes. Yeah, all of that. So we really went down memory lane. But he also told me that he was in charge of all of the items on our desk, including all of the plants in the office. So here is what he told me about Pam's plants at reception. Wait, did you tell him that I'm obsessed with him? Yes.
你记得吗？是的。是的，所有这些。所以我们真的走了一趟记忆之旅。但他还告诉我，他负责我们桌子上所有的物品，包括办公室里所有的植物。所以这是他告诉我的关于帕姆在前台的植物的事。等等，你告诉他我对他着迷了吗？是的。
Because I had to explain why I was suddenly calling him to ask him multiple questions about the plants on the reception desk. I had to give some context. So he didn't think you were crazy. No, I mean, he might still think we're crazy. But, I mean, he's like retired and living in Oregon now. So, all right, here is what he told me, Angie. So you might remember he had a little office on our stages that was behind Michael Scott's office. Oh, yeah.
因为我必须解释为什么我突然打电话给他问他关于前台植物的多个问题。我必须提供一些背景。这样他就不会觉得你疯了。不，我的意思是，他可能还是觉得我们疯了。但是，我的意思是，他现在退休住在俄勒冈州了。所以，好吧，这是他告诉我的，安吉。所以你可能记得他在我们的舞台上有一个小办公室，就在迈克尔·斯科特办公室后面。哦，是的。
I remember it. It was like a wooden, like they built him like a. wooden kind of shed right there. Yes. And lining his walls were all kinds of chotch keys and things that he would place all around the office. Yes. So right outside of his office, he had a tiny, like, grow station and a plant care station for all of the plants in the office. He said for Pam's desk, he had only about three different plants and they were in plastic pots and he would rotate them randomly but he had an assortment as we've noticed of ceramic pots so that was how he kind of
我记得。那就像一个木制的，就像他们给他建了一个木头棚子在那里。是的。他的墙上排满了各种各样的装饰品和东西，他会把它们放在办公室各处。是的。所以就在他办公室外面，他有一个小小的，就像一个生长站和植物护理站，负责办公室里所有的植物。他说对于帕姆的桌子，他只有大约三种不同的植物，它们放在塑料盆里，他会随机轮换它们，但他有我们注意到的各种陶瓷盆，所以这就是他如何
tried to make them look different he said that it was absolutely totally random what plant he put on the desk because I asked him about the flowering plant for beach games and If it was symbolic that Pam bloomed in that episode and he laughed and he said, no, that's just a wonderful coincidence. He told me that Greg was very, very strict about the set decoration and that they were not allowed to change anything without Greg's permission. Tiny details they would get in trouble. He said Greg never noticed the changing plants and he never consulted Greg about the plants. It was his own little thing that he did each week. This is his own small act of rebellion that he would have different plants.
试图让它们看起来不同。他说他放在桌子上的植物完全是随机的，因为我问过他关于海滩游戏那集的开花植物，以及帕姆在那一集中绽放是否具有象征意义，他笑了，他说：“不，那只是一个美妙的巧合。”他告诉我，格雷格对布景装饰非常非常严格，如果没有格雷格的许可，他们不允许改变任何东西。微小的细节他们都会惹上麻烦。他说格雷格从来没注意到植物的变化，他也从来没咨询过格雷格关于植物的事。这是他每周自己做的小事。这是他自己小小的反叛行为，每周都有不同的植物。
Yes. Well, Steve, I noticed. Angela noticed, Steve. He said that he thinks he did a Christmas cactus once and that over the holiday episodes, he would always try to do something maybe a little different. But mostly it was just these little ferns. I will be looking. for that Christmas cactus.
是的。好吧，史蒂夫，我注意到了。安吉拉注意到了，史蒂夫。他说他认为他曾经做过一次圣诞仙人掌，在节日剧集里，他总是会尝试做一些可能有点不同的事情。但大多时候只是这些小蕨类植物。我会留意的。为了那个圣诞仙人掌。
Oh, me too. I got so excited. I was like, oh, I don't think we've seen that yet. We haven't seen Christmas cactus. Everybody look out for Christmas cactus. I'm going to have to go back to the Christmas episodes, but I do not remember a cactus. Well, here's the other thing.
哦，我也是。我太兴奋了。我说：“哦，我觉得我们还没看到那个。”我们还没见过圣诞仙人掌。大家留意圣诞仙人掌。我得回去看圣诞剧集，但我真的不记得有仙人掌。好吧，还有一件事。
He told me, Angela, he would have to water all those plants. And if we ever went on a week-long hiatus, he would take all the plants off the set and he would put them under grow lights and Tom Melby would come and water them on our breaks. I believe that, Tom Melby. I believe that.
他告诉我，安吉拉，他得给所有那些植物浇水。如果我们休假一周，他会把所有的植物从片场拿走，放在生长灯下，汤姆·梅尔比会在我们休息时来给它们浇水。我相信这一点，汤姆·梅尔比。我相信。
That's so sweet. I remember Steve, he would walk over to accounting and water the plant that was on the file cabinets between accounting and reception. And we would chit-chat. Well, here's the other thing he told me. What? Not plant related. Steve Doucherer was also in charge of all of the plaques around the office. He made all of them, including that one.
太甜了。我记得史蒂夫，他会走到会计部，给会计和前台之间文件柜上的植物浇水。我们会闲聊。好吧，还有一件事他告诉了我。什么？不是关于植物的。史蒂夫·杜舍尔还负责办公室周围所有的牌匾。他制作了所有这些，包括那个
that trolled Kelly Cantley. No. Yep. He was also in charge of the white board by accounting, and he said he was the one who wrote that Steve was robbed after the Emmys that one year. Oh, I love it. Steve, look at you. You're like over there mixing up plants.
嘲弄凯利·坎特利的牌匾。不。是的。他还负责会计部旁边的白板，他说那一年艾美奖后写着“史蒂夫被抢了”的人就是他。哦，我喜欢。史蒂夫，看看你。你就像在那儿摆弄植物。
You're writing secret messages on the message board. Yes. He told me that this job was just his favorite, and it was wonderful. And we just talked about what a special thing we had. And he retired when the show ended. He was like, I don't think it's going to get better. And he retired. Steve, you're not wrong.
你在留言板上写秘密信息。是的。他告诉我这份工作是他最喜欢的，非常棒。我们只是谈论了我们拥有的那种特别的东西。他在节目结束时退休了。他说：“我觉得不会有更好的了。”然后他退休了。史蒂夫，你没说错。
You're not wrong. We've worked on other shows and we've had good experiences and things. But I have to say, it'd be pretty amazing to be able to just ride off in the sunset after a show like the office. Because it was that special. Mm-hmm. Well, lady, you know you got me that Morgan Gassell. watercolor of the Beasley's botanicals for Christmas, everybody. Angela got me this.
你没说错。我们在其他节目工作过，也有过很好的经历。但我不得不说，在像《办公室》这样的节目之后能骑马走向夕阳真是太棒了。因为它就是那么特别。嗯哼。好吧，女士，你知道你为圣诞节给我买了那个摩根·加塞尔的《比斯利植物学》水彩画，大家。安吉拉给我买了这幅画。
I mean, I could not be more excited. This is Jenna's Christmas present from me. I got her, Morgan, you're so talented. You painted all of Pam's plants. And Morgan gave me the original. She also gave me a painting of all of Angela Martin's weird blouses. Yes, I've seen that. Yes.
我的意思是，我再兴奋不过了。这是珍娜从我这儿收到的圣诞礼物。我给她买了，摩根，你太有才了。你画了帕姆所有的植物。摩根给了我原件。她还给了我一幅安吉拉·马丁所有奇怪衬衫的画。是的，我见过那个。是的。
And Jenna. and a coffee mug of Pam's botanicals, Jenna. Amazing. Amazing. Well, I sent a print of Beasley's botanicals to Steve as a thank you. Oh, that is so sweet. I thought the man in charge should have a print as well. Yes.
还有珍娜。还有帕姆植物学的咖啡杯，珍娜。太棒了。太棒了。好吧，我寄了一份《比斯利植物学》的印刷品给史蒂夫作为感谢。哦，那太甜了。我觉得负责的人也应该有一份印刷品。是的。
Oh, I love that. He also sent me a photo of himself in his office on stage. And now that I've told you, I can send it to you. And guys, he said we can put it up. on Office Ladies' pod as well. Oh, we will. And we'll put up some of Morgan's stuff so you can see in our stories. And this was wonderful. I loved it. And guys, if you want to get one, go over to Society 6. It's the number 6 and search for Beasley's botanicals. And it'll pop up and you can get one yourself. Well, let's take a break. And then when we come back, we will really get into this
哦，我喜欢那个。他还发给我一张他在舞台办公室里的照片。现在我告诉你了，我可以发给你。伙计们，他说我们可以把它贴在《办公室女士》的播客上。哦，我们会贴的。我们还会贴一些摩根的东西，这样你们可以在我们的故事里看到。这太棒了。我喜欢它。伙计们，如果你想买一个，去Society 6。是数字6，搜索“Beasley's botanicals”。它就会弹出来，你可以自己买一个。好吧，我们休息一下。然后回来后，我们将真正进入这一集。
episode. Michael is not going to react well to the pizza delivery. Oh, no, it's not going to be good. The holidays are here, and that means it's the most wonderful time of the year to save with Rackaton. Use Racketon to stack cashback at your favorite stores on top of holiday sales. That's savings on savings. With Rackaton, you can get cash back on gifts for everyone on your list, from toys for the kids to kitchen gear, for the person who loves to. to cook to electronics for everyone.
迈克尔对披萨外卖的反应不会很好。哦，不，那不会有好结果的。假期到了，这意味着这是用乐天（Rakuten）省钱的一年中最美妙的时光。使用乐天在您最喜欢的商店叠加现金返还，再加上节日促销。那是省上加省。有了乐天，您可以为您名单上的每个人获得礼物的现金返还，从给孩子的玩具到厨房用具，给喜欢做饭的人，再到给每个人的电子产品。
You can even save on something for yourself. Just shop the stores you love and cashback is automatically added to your account and you can choose to get paid via Interact E-transfer, PayPal, or check. Join for free today and get a new member bonus after minimum qualifying purchases. Just go to rackettin.ca. Download the app or install the browser extension. That's R-A-K-U-T-E-N. Terms and conditions apply.
您甚至可以为您自己省钱。只需在您喜欢的商店购物，现金返还就会自动添加到您的账户中，您可以选择通过Interact电子转账、PayPal或支票获得付款。今天免费加入，并在最低合格购买后获得新会员奖金。只需前往rackettin.ca。下载应用程序或安装浏览器扩展。那是R-A-K-U-T-E-N。条款和条件适用。
All right, we are back, everyone, and we are going to open this episode with Michael and Jim returning from their very short road trip where they got, I don't even think, outside of Scranton before realizing that they're not invited to the big New York party. So they come back and Michael makes a big announcement, like, he actually wanted to be at the Scranton branch party. He actually didn't want to go to New York, right? Yes. And Stanley's like, wait, so we're not going home early? Michael's like, no. No. In fact, Michael calls Angela into his office and he says to Angela, I want this party to be sexier, cooler, and more important than the one in New York. And he gives her a list of demands. Yeah. Let's just talk about this list for a minute. Okay. Now, remember, the party starts in. One hour. Yeah. This is the list. Ready? Beer, light beer, streamers, orchids, better lighting, something made of ice. Pizza, pizza with mushrooms, pizza without mushrooms, white pizza, steak, chocolates, someone famous, cool music, confetti, go go dancers, maybe Al Roker. Yeah. Guess what? Michael says he'll get the pizza, since Angela's going to do all those other things in one hour. Yeah. I mean, he wants the people in New York to be jealous. they got Al Roker to attend in Scranton.
好了，我们回来了，大家，我们要以迈克尔和吉姆从他们非常短暂的公路旅行回来开始这一集，他们在意识到没被邀请参加纽约的大型派对之前，甚至我觉得都没离开斯克兰顿。所以他们回来了，迈克尔宣布了一个大消息，就像，他其实想参加斯克兰顿分部的派对。他其实不想去纽约，对吧？是的。斯坦利说：“等等，所以我们不用早点回家？”迈克尔说：“不。不。事实上，迈克尔把安吉拉叫进办公室，他对安吉拉说：‘我想要这个派对比纽约的那个更性感、更酷、更重要。’他给了她一份需求清单。”是的。让我们谈谈这份清单。好的。现在记住，派对开始于。一小时后。是的。这是清单。准备好了吗？啤酒、淡啤酒、彩带、兰花、更好的照明、冰做的东西。披萨、蘑菇披萨、无蘑菇披萨、白披萨、牛排、巧克力、名人、酷音乐、五彩纸屑、舞者，也许是阿尔·罗克。是的。猜猜怎么着？迈克尔说他会去买披萨，因为安吉拉要在这一小时内做所有那些其他事情。是的。我的意思是，他想让纽约的人嫉妒。他们请到了阿尔·罗克参加斯克兰顿的派对。
How is that so hard to understand, Angela? I don't know. Just go get some go-go dancers and some steak, possibly change the whole lighting scheme of the office. That'd be great. Thanks. But he tells Angela, if anyone can do it, it's you. But actually, if there is someone who could do it better, could you let him know?
这有什么难理解的，安吉拉？我不知道。去买些舞者和牛排，可能还要改变办公室的整个照明方案。那太棒了。谢谢。但他告诉安吉拉，如果有人能做到，那就是你。但其实，如果有人能做得更好，你能告诉他吗？
What was it like for you to do that scene with Steve? Were you improvising any of the things on that list as you were reading them off? Or was that pretty much scripted? No, that was pretty much scripted. And it was really fun because Steve has to interrupt me. And I just loved, love doing scenes with him. It felt like I got to be like in this comedic dance, you know? And except I'm dancing with like the best comedian in town.
你和史蒂夫演那场戏是什么感觉？你在读清单时是在即兴发挥吗？还是那基本上是写好的剧本？不，那基本上是写好的。而且真的很有趣，因为史蒂夫不得不打断我。我只是喜欢，喜欢和他演戏。感觉就像我能参与到这场喜剧舞蹈中，你知道吗？除了我是在和城里最好的喜剧演员跳舞。
It just was so fun. I was like, you know how you have like a body buzz, you know? Yeah. Like I had that kind of feeling going in there to get to do scenes with him. and I loved every single second. And he would be so generous. We've talked about this. But he'd let me have a moment.
这太有趣了。我当时想，你知道那种身体嗡嗡作响的感觉吗？是的。就像我进去和他演戏时有那种感觉。我喜欢每一秒。他会非常慷慨。我们谈过这个。但他会让我有一个时刻。
Like when I say steak and I look at him, you know? Like he just let all of that breathe. I know exactly that body buzz you're talking about because I would get that feeling every time I'd get a script and be like, there's a Pam Michael scene. I get Steve all to myself. Yeah. And he's just so good.
比如当我说“牛排”然后看着他的时候，你知道吗？他只是让这一切呼吸。我完全明白你在说的那种身体嗡嗡作响的感觉，因为每次我拿到剧本，看到“帕姆和迈克尔的戏”，我就会有那种感觉。我一个人拥有史蒂夫。是的。他太棒了。
And I feel like every person in a scene with Steve, Steve makes that person better. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Well, I love that scene. I watched it. I rewound it and watched it a second time just because it was so, so delightful. Yes. And I had to memorize that list, guys. I'm not reading off. Oh, my gosh. That wasn't written on the piece of paper for you? No. I mean, you know, like, maybe the prop department had a list, but I had to learn that. Well, and it's important because some of those elements are going to come up later, right? So you had to make sure you said certain things. Yeah.
我觉得每个和史蒂夫演戏的人，史蒂夫都会让那个人变得更好。哦，是的。是的。好吧，我喜欢那场戏。我看了。我倒回去看了第二遍，因为它太、太令人愉快了。是的。我得背下那份清单，伙计们。我不是在读。天哪。那张纸上没写给你吗？不。我的意思是，你知道，也许道具部门有一份清单，但我得学那个。嗯，这很重要，因为其中一些元素稍后会出现，对吧？所以你得确保你说某些事情。是的。
Well, next up, Andy is trying to talk to Dwight to see what does he think about Angela? Does he think that Andy should go after Angela? And Dwight is like, no. The first thing he says, which if you speak Dwight, you know, is one of the highest compliments he could give anyone. He says, she's efficient. Well, that's just like, that's like stabbing Dwight. in the heart right there. Yeah.
好吧，接下来，安迪试图和德怀特谈谈，看看他对安吉拉有什么看法？他觉得安迪应该追求安吉拉吗？德怀特说：“不。”他说的第一件事，如果你懂德怀特的话，你知道这是他能给任何人的最高赞美之一。他说：“她很有效率。”好吧，那就像，那就像刺伤德怀特。就在心脏那里。是的。
That he's lost such an efficient woman. Yeah. And, you know, Dwight does not obviously want Andy to make a play for Angela. So he tells her it's inappropriate to date someone at work. And he could actually date Kelly because she's in the annex. Like he can date Kelly or Toby, but not anyone in their immediate bullpen. Yeah. Well, now Michael triumphantly announces that he has ordered pizza from everybody's favorite place.
他失去了这样一个高效的女人。是的。而且，你知道，德怀特显然不希望安迪追求安吉拉。所以他告诉她，在工作中和某人约会是不合适的。他其实可以和凯利约会，因为她在附楼。就像他可以和凯利或托比约会，但不能是他们直接办公区里的任何人。是的。好吧，现在迈克尔得意洋洋地宣布他从大家最喜欢的地方订了披萨。
Everyone gets kind of excited until they learn that Michael ordered pizza from the wrong place. Well, you know, clearly the favorite of Dundermifflin is Alfredo's Pizza Cafe. And Michael has ordered from pizza by Alfredos, which Kevin describes as like eating a hot circle of garbage. Well, Michael asks, what's better, a medium amount of good pizza or all you can eat of pretty good pizza? and everyone is like a medium amount of good pizza. Yes. But Jenna, this sent me on one of the craziest deep dives I have done in the year that we've been podcasting together. Well, I hope that you're going to tell me some stuff about Alfredo's Pizza Cafe because we got a fan question about this.
每个人都变得有点兴奋，直到他们发现迈克尔从错误的地方订了披萨。嗯，你知道，邓德·米夫林显然最喜欢的是阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆。而迈克尔从阿尔弗雷多披萨店订了餐，凯文形容那就像在吃一个热的垃圾圆圈。好吧，迈克尔问：“什么是更好的，适量的美味披萨，还是无限量的还不错的披萨？”每个人都说：“适量的美味披萨。”是的。但珍娜，这让我踏上了我们一起做播客这一年来我做过的最疯狂的深入挖掘之一。嗯，我希望你会告诉我一些关于阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆的事情，因为我们收到了一个关于这个的粉丝问题。
Oh, yes. And more. More information you'll ever want to know. All right. Well, Catalina Rizzi and Paisley-Zelladon would like to know are Pizza by Alfredo and Alfredo's Pizza Cafe, actual pizza places in Scranton? Well, Alfredo's Pizza Cafe is in fact a real pizza place. It's opened every day. It's still open in Scranton. And Pizza by Alfredo is a made-up place that the writer's made up. But Alfredo's Pizza Cafe is in Scranton and you can still get pizzas from there today. And Angela, I'll have you know, Angela, the character, could have ordered steak because Alfredo's Pizza Cafe also serves steak, burgers, and pasta. Oh yeah, it's a cafe. It's like a
哦，是的。还有更多。比你想要知道的更多的信息。好的。好吧，卡塔琳娜·里齐和佩斯利·泽拉登想知道阿尔弗雷多披萨店和阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆是斯克兰顿真实的披萨店吗？嗯，阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆确实是一家真实的披萨店。它每天都营业。它在斯克兰顿仍然营业。而阿尔弗雷多披萨店是编剧编造的一个地方。但阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆在斯克兰顿，你今天仍然可以从那里买到披萨。而且安吉拉，我要让你知道，安吉拉这个角色本来可以点牛排，因为阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆也供应牛排、汉堡和意大利面。哦，是的，它是一家咖啡馆。它就像一家
restaurant. Yes. Well, I was very curious. I just wrote in Alfredo's Pizza into my Google search. Okay. Because I was like, I wonder if this is just in Scranton. Or do we have Alfredo's Pizza? other places, right? Yep. So here we go. In Homewood, Alabama, there's Alfredo's Pizza Cafe. In California, there's Alfredo's pizza in Los Angeles. In Colorado, there's an Alfredo's pizza in Denver.
餐馆。是的。好吧，我很好奇。我只是在谷歌搜索里输入了“阿尔弗雷多披萨”。好的。因为我在想，我想知道这是否只在斯克兰顿。还是我们在其他地方也有阿尔弗雷多披萨，对吧？是的。所以我们开始吧。在阿拉巴马州的霍姆伍德，有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆。在加利福尼亚州，洛杉矶有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨。在科罗拉多州，丹佛有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨。
In Connecticut, there's an Alfredo's restaurant and pizza in Gaylord'sville. In Delaware, there's an Alfredo's Pizza Gallery in Seaford. In Florida, there's an Alfredo's pizza and restaurant in Cooper City. In Illinois, there's an Alfredo's pizza and pasta in Lake in the Hills. In Iowa, there's an Alfredo pizza. We'll let it slide, Iowa. That's in Sioux City. In Maine, there's Alfredo's Italian pizzeria in Wells.
在康涅狄格州，盖洛德斯维尔有一家阿尔弗雷多餐厅和披萨店。在特拉华州，西福德有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨画廊。在佛罗里达州，库珀城有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨和餐厅。在伊利诺伊州，莱克因希尔斯有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨和意大利面。在爱荷华州，有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨。我们让它过去吧，爱荷华。那是在苏城。在缅因州，威尔斯有一家阿尔弗雷多意大利披萨店。
In Maryland, there's Osteria Alfredo in Easton. In Massachusetts, there's Alfredo's Italian Kitchen in Boston, Somerville, and Medford. In New Jersey, there's an Alfredo's in Carteret. There's an Alfredo's restaurant in Pizzeria in Point Pleasant. There's a cafe Alfredo's in Somerset. In New York, there's an Alfredo's Pizza Cafe in New Rochelle. In North Carolina, there's an Alfredo's Pizza Villa in Chapel Hill. Alfredo's restaurante Italiano and Clinton.
在马里兰州，伊斯顿有一家Osteria Alfredo。在马萨诸塞州，波士顿、萨默维尔和梅德福有阿尔弗雷多意大利厨房。在新泽西州，卡特雷特有一家阿尔弗雷多。点普莱森特有一家阿尔弗雷多餐厅和披萨店。萨默塞特有一家阿尔弗雷多咖啡馆。在纽约，新罗谢尔有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨咖啡馆。在北卡罗来纳州，教堂山有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨别墅。克林顿有一家阿尔弗雷多意大利餐厅。
Wait for it. In Ohio, there's Alfredo's Pizzeria in Salem. In Pennsylvania, there's Alfredo's Pizza and Restaurant in Scranton. And Alfredo's Pizza and Grill in Swiftwater. In South Dakota, there's a restaurant. an Alfredo pizza in Vermillion. We'll let it slide, South Dakota. In Texas, there's Alfredo's pizza and pasta in Dallas.
等着瞧。在俄亥俄州，塞勒姆有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨店。在宾夕法尼亚州，斯克兰顿有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨和餐厅。斯威夫特沃特有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨和烧烤店。在南达科他州，有一家餐厅。一家阿尔弗雷多披萨店在弗米利恩。我们让它过去吧，南达科他。在德克萨斯州，达拉斯有一家阿尔弗雷多披萨和意大利面。
Alfredos in Plano and Alfredos in Louisville. Utah has Chef Alfredos in St. George and Cedar City. Virginia has Alfredos in Bristol. Now, are you ready for this? Who has the most that comes up in a Google search? West Virginia. West Virginia has Alfredos in Somerville. Alfredo's Italian Pizzeria in Petersburg, Alfredo's Pizza of Rainville, Lewisburg, White Silver Springs, Buckhannon, Alfredo's Italian, and Greek, because, okay, in Marlinton, and Alfredo's in the Crossroads Mall in Mount Hope.
普莱诺有Alfredos，路易斯维尔也有Alfredos。犹他州的圣乔治和锡达城有Chef Alfredos。弗吉尼亚州的布里斯托有Alfredos。现在，准备好了吗？在谷歌搜索中出现次数最多的是谁？西弗吉尼亚州。西弗吉尼亚州的萨默维尔有Alfredos。彼得斯堡有Alfredo's Italian Pizzeria，雷恩维尔、刘易斯堡、白硫磺泉镇、巴克汉农有Alfredo's Pizza，马林顿有Alfredo's Italian and Greek（因为，好吧），芒特霍普的十字路口购物中心里也有Alfredo's。
I love you. There's Alfredos everywhere. I love you. There's Alfredos everywhere. Guys, I watched Angela, as she listed all of the Alfredos, and it was three pages long. Well, if I didn't say your state, it's because there was no Alfredo's that came up in the Google search, but I looked up every single state. Well, you know, the one in Scranton is not actually called Alfredo's Pizza Cafe. It's just called Alfredo's Cafe.
我爱你。到处都是Alfredos。我爱你。到处都是Alfredos。伙计们，我看着安吉拉列出所有的Alfredos，足足有三页纸那么长。好吧，如果我没提到你的州，那是因为在谷歌搜索中没有出现Alfredo's，但我查了每一个州。嗯，你知道，斯克兰顿的那家其实不叫Alfredo's Pizza Cafe。它只叫Alfredo's Cafe。
That's right. And it says their slogan, please tell me their slogan is, we're not a hot circle of garbage. Because if that's not their slogan, it should be. Here is Alfredo's cafe's slogan. We're not fine dining. We're just fine food. I like it. I still think not a hot circle of garbage might be something they should consider.
没错。而且他们的标语写着，请告诉我他们的标语是“我们不是一团滚烫的垃圾”。因为如果那不是他们的标语，那它就应该是。这是Alfredo's Cafe的标语：我们不是高级餐厅，我们只是提供不错的食物。我喜欢这个。但我还是觉得“不是一团滚烫的垃圾”可能是他们应该考虑的标语。
Well, Alfredos, you heard it from Jenna. Get your marketing team on it. Yeah. She's not wrong. I want to talk about something from this scene that has nothing to do with the pizza. Okay. Can we please talk about your weird? ass blouse in this episode. Oh, Jenna. I'm sorry to curse, but guys, it is weird. It is so weird.
好吧，Alfredos，你们从珍娜那儿听到了。让你们的营销团队去处理吧。是的。她说得没错。我想谈谈这一幕中与披萨无关的事情。好吧。我们能谈谈你这一集中那件奇怪的衬衫吗？哦，珍娜。抱歉我说了脏话，但伙计们，它真的很奇怪。太奇怪了。
And actually, now, listen, later in the episode, I'm going to give you a time code that really zooms in on the sweater. In particular, the part I want to talk about. But just know, it's called the elbow poof. All right. Well, I'll wait till we get to the appropriate time code. I can wait. Yeah, but it's a bizarro sweater. It's got a poofy part at your elbow. Well, moving us along then, Angela, in this next scene, Phyllis comes in to the conference room to confront Angela again. She maybe is using some of her techniques from the last episode on how to deal with difficult people. And she has placed items on post-it notes and then put a post-it note on each finger.
其实，听着，在这一集的后面，我会给你们一个时间码，可以真正放大看那件毛衣。特别是我想谈论的部分。但只要知道，它叫“肘部泡泡袖”。好吧，我会等到我们到达相应的时间码。我可以等。是的，但那是一件怪异的毛衣。你的肘部有一个蓬松的部分。好吧，那我们继续往下说，安吉拉，在下一幕中，菲利斯走进会议室再次与安吉拉对质。她可能正在使用上一集中学到的处理困难人物的技巧。她在便利贴上写了项目，然后把便利贴贴在每个手指上。
And she says to Angela, you can pick one of these. one of these. I'll do one, but I can't do all of these. This is her visual way of showing you how you've overwhelmed her with too many tasks. Well, let me tell you, this is some serious Phyllis sass. She wads them up. She throws them in my face. And I want you to know, it did kind of hurt. That owl was kind of honest because when you crumple up paper, it's like pointy. Yeah. And also, I think that was the only usable take. I'm not kidding. laughed every time she threw him in my face, she would laugh every time. And so that, to me, when I was watching it, I just was remembering us cracking up. And it just made me so happy.
她对安吉拉说，你可以选一个。选一个。我可以做一个，但我不能做所有这些。这是她向你展示你如何用太多的任务压垮她的视觉方式。好吧，让我告诉你，这可是菲利斯非常严肃的讽刺。她把它们揉成一团。她把它们扔到我脸上。我想让你知道，这确实有点疼。那团纸有点硬，因为当你把纸揉成一团时，它就像尖尖的。是的。而且，我认为那是唯一可用的镜头。我没开玩笑。每次她把它们扔到我脸上时，她都会笑，她每次都会笑。所以，当我观看它时，我只是记得我们笑得前仰后合。这让我感到非常快乐。
Well, anytime Phyllis has to do something like that, she can't do it because it is so against her nature. It is so against her sweet, kind, loving nature that she just giggles. She gets the giggles. Yes. Well, next up, Angela, we have this scene. And I have some things to ask you about. Andy is attempting to ask Angela out, but she is searching through this box of party supplies. What do you think you're going to find in there? What are you looking for in this box? A steak, an ice sculpture?
好吧，每当菲利斯不得不做那样的事情时，她都做不到，因为它太违背她的天性了。这太违背她甜美、善良、充满爱心的天性了，以至于她只会咯咯笑。她会忍不住咯咯笑。是的。好吧，接下来，安吉拉，我们有这一幕。我有一些事情要问你。安迪试图约安吉拉出去，但她正在翻找那个派对用品盒。你觉得你在里面能找到什么？你在找什么？牛排，冰雕？
You think any of the things on Michael's list, better lighting? It's a small box. It's a busy work box, Jenna. It's a box so I could look busy and I could ignore Andy. and what I gave to myself was like, clearly I'm looking for more of those weird blue spiral thingies that I'm going to hang in the conference room later. She had a vision of blue spiral thingies and she needed more of them. And so she's digging and digging.
你觉得迈克尔名单上的任何东西，更好的照明？那是个小盒子。那是个装忙碌工作的盒子，珍娜。那是个盒子，所以我可以看起来很忙，我可以忽略安迪。我给自己的理由是，显然我在找更多那种奇怪的蓝色螺旋状小东西，我稍后要挂在会议室里。她对蓝色螺旋状小东西有种执念，她需要更多。所以她一直在挖啊挖。
But who uses this as a pickup line? Who thinks that a woman is going to like stop everything she's doing in your, and just be like, you're right. There's not dinner in a movie in this box. well lady we also have a fan catch here from abbey tilford okay she says in launch party around 16 minutes 25 seconds so this was a moment from last week's breakdown Angela says she's been working on the party for two weeks but now at 25 minutes 21 seconds she says she's been planning it for three weeks Is this just Angela being dramatic?
但谁会用这个作为搭讪语？谁会认为一个女人会停下她正在做的一切，然后说，你是对的。这个盒子里没有晚餐和电影。好吧，女士，我们这里还有一个来自艾比·蒂尔福德的粉丝发现。她说，在《发布会》大约16分25秒处，所以这是上周回顾中的一个时刻，安吉拉说她已经为派对工作了两周，但现在在25分21秒处，她说她已经计划了三周。这只是安吉拉在演戏吗？
What is this? This is a bit of a continuity catch. And I looked, she's right. Oh, no, she's right. It's a continuity error. And maybe we can justify it by saying that Angela feels very put upon all of a sudden. So maybe she's exaggerating. And I have an improv catch.
这是什么？这是一个小小的连续性漏洞。我查了一下，她是正确的。哦，不，她是正确的。这是一个连续性错误。也许我们可以通过说安吉拉突然感到压力很大来证明这一点。所以也许她在夸大其词。我还有一个即兴表演的发现。
I improvised the last line as I walked away. I said, and Kevin had Greek food for lunch again. I love that. That was an improv? Yes. That was an improv. you don't see is that Matt Sone cut over to Brian as Kevin and he was like, hey, I love that your character's go to is always to find some subtle way to insult Kevin. Yeah, of course. Because
我即兴发挥了最后一句台词，当我走开时。我说，凯文午餐又吃了希腊菜。我喜欢那个。那是即兴发挥？是的。那是即兴发挥。你没看到的是，马特·索恩切到了布莱恩饰演的凯文，他当时就像，嘿，我喜欢你角色的拿手好戏总是找到某种微妙的方式来侮辱凯文。是的，当然。因为
he's a constant annoyance for her, constant, all day long. I'm telling you, I think she requested the glass partition. He drives her crazy. She needed a barrier. Well, now we have a little a Pam sass coming up. The pizza guy has arrived. And Pam calls Michael and says, hey, the pizza by Alfredo guy is here. Michael says, you don't have to say it like that. And Pam says, I said it normal. I did say it normal. I know, but I just love that Pam, this is this new. I'm in love Pam. I give zero Fs. I say what I think. And I loved it. But yes, the pizza guy is here. And oh, man, this starts a whole Michael spiral. everything he is feeling about Ryan and feeling left out and not treated fairly,
他一直让她感到厌烦，一直，整天都是。我告诉你，我认为她要求安装玻璃隔断。他让她抓狂。她需要一个屏障。好吧，现在我们要迎来一点帕姆的讽刺了。披萨送货员到了。帕姆打电话给迈克尔说，嘿，阿尔弗雷多披萨的人来了。迈克尔说，你没必要那样说。帕姆说，我说得很正常。我确实说得很正常。我知道，但我只是喜欢帕姆，这是新的。我是恋爱中的帕姆。我一点也不在乎。我说我想说的。我喜欢它。但是是的，披萨送货员来了。哦，天哪，这引发了迈克尔的一连串连锁反应。他关于瑞安的所有感受，感到被冷落，没有得到公平对待，
he is going to pile on this poor teenager who's just a pizza delivery guy. Yeah, he is mad because the pizza kid will not accept his half-off coupon for all of the pizzas. He explains, you can have half-off two pizzas, but not all of the pizzas. And Michael is like, it doesn't say that anywhere on the coupon. And the pizza kid is like, I don't know what to tell you. I mean, he's basically like, if I give you half off all these pizzas and I go back, I'm going to get in trouble. This is not, I mean, it's not my decision to make. I can't authorize your new use of this coupon.
他要把这一切都发泄在这个可怜的青少年身上，他只是一个披萨送货员。是的，他很生气，因为披萨小子不接受他那张所有披萨半价的优惠券。他解释说，你可以两份披萨半价，但不能所有披萨都半价。迈克尔说，优惠券上任何地方都没写。披萨小子说，我不知道该怎么跟你说。我的意思是，他基本上是说，如果我给你所有这些披萨半价，我回去会惹麻烦的。这不是，我的意思是，这不是我能决定的。我不能授权你这样使用这张优惠券。
Well, and listen, the pizza guy does have a little bit of that teenage sass, though, because he's like, not my problem. A little bit full teenager sass. Listen, this truly isn't his problem. and Michael needs to lighten up, but the kid is also kind of an ass. For sure. Well, Michael's response to this
好吧，听着，披萨送货员确实有一点那种青少年的傲慢，因为他说，那不是我的问题。有点十足的青少年傲慢。听着，这真的不是他的问题。迈克尔需要放轻松，但这个孩子也有点混蛋。当然。好吧，迈克尔对此的回应
is to have Dwight lock him in the conference room until he decides to honor the coupon. It's so irrational. He says that he needs to learn about respect and accountability and follow through. He's saying all this crazy stuff.
是让德怀特把他锁在会议室里，直到他决定兑现优惠券。这太不理智了。他说他需要学习尊重、责任和执行力。他在说所有这些疯狂的话。
And then, of course, he really loses it and is like, the guy is like, this is stupid. He's like, you don't even know what stupid is. It's about to get a stupid up in here. This is such an outrageous storyline. As I was watching this episode, I just kept thinking, I can't believe we are doing this storyline.
然后，当然，他真的失控了，说，那家伙说，这太蠢了。他说，你根本不知道什么是蠢。这里马上就要变得蠢起来了。这是一个如此离谱的故事情节。当我观看这一集时，我一直想，我不敢相信我们正在做这个故事情节。
It is so funny. It is really broad. It's really broad. But yet at the same time, you kind of believe that Michael would do it, that Michael would be like, no, you're going to stay here and you're going to learn a lesson. And everyone around him is like, you have just kidnapped someone. you are currently holding someone hostage. And he's like, no, no, no, I'm teaching him a lesson.
这太搞笑了。它真的很宽泛。它真的很宽泛。但与此同时，你又有点相信迈克尔会这样做，迈克尔会说，不，你要留在这里，你要吸取教训。他周围的每个人都说，你刚刚绑架了某人。你现在正在扣押人质。他说，不，不，不，我是在教他一个教训。
Well, yeah, Kevin, Oscar Stanley, they have all started researching kidnapping and accomplices to see if they can be charged as, you know, accessories to Michael's crime. But this is what Michael does, you know. It's like in the episode when he drives his car in the lake, he takes it out on the guy who ate the turtles from the gift basket. He always, like, shifts the blame and responsibility. If Michael is embarrassed or if Michael is upset about something, he takes it out on a very ordinary moment. And it's so funny. And we've all sort of been there, right? We've all had that displaced anger.
好吧，是的，凯文、奥斯卡、斯坦利，他们都开始研究绑架和共犯，看看他们是否会被指控为，你知道，迈克尔犯罪的从犯。但这就是迈克尔所做的，你知道。就像他在把车开进湖里的那一集一样，他把气撒在那个吃了礼品篮里乌龟的人身上。他总是，像，转移责备和责任。如果迈克尔感到尴尬，或者如果迈克尔对某事感到不安，他会把它发泄在一个非常普通的时刻。这太搞笑了。我们都经历过，对吧？我们都有过那种被转移的愤怒。
Like, I'll never forget one time my dad had, he had ordered this new barbecue grill. And Jenna, this guy in my hometown makes them, you know, like a smoker and he's a welder. And he made my dad this smoker. And it took him a while because he makes it, you know, by hand. He's out there welding. And my dad went to get it and he got a flatbed trailer to put it on and pull it behind our truck. He was so excited. We'd waited so long.
就像，我永远不会忘记有一次我爸爸订购了这个新的烧烤架。珍娜，我老家有个家伙制作这些，你知道，像烟熏炉，他是个焊工。他给我爸爸做了这个烟熏炉。这花了他一段时间，因为他是手工制作的，你知道。他在外面焊接。我爸爸去取它，他弄了一辆平板拖车把它放在上面，拉在我们卡车后面。他太兴奋了。我们等了太久了。
And he's driving down the driveway with it. And he didn't, like, factor in, like, the overhang of the carport and dented in the new smoke. Oh, no. Yeah. And for whatever reason, he got a, we were all like, don't say anything, don't say anything. He got out of the car and he was like, if that tree hadn't been there, then he was like going to cut down the tree. And my mom was like, it's not the tree's fault. Leave the tree out of it. You know, but we've all had these moments where we're so like upset and irrationally. We're like, that's it. It's the tree. Oh my gosh. Well, speaking of tree, we were all set to get our Christmas tree on this one day we were going to set up the Christmas tree. And I can't remember what happened. It was like something. And it was the night before. And I said to Lee, I said, so we're getting up early in the morning. We're going to go get our tree. We're going to decorate the tree tomorrow. And he said very casually, well, I don't know. I mean tomorrow or another day. And I was like, what? It's going to be tomorrow at 9 a.m. And I like, I was like a mess.
他正开着车沿着车道走。他没有，像，考虑到，像，车棚的悬挑，把新的烟熏炉撞凹了。哦，不。是的，不管什么原因，他变得，我们都像，什么都别说，什么都别说。他从车里出来，他说，如果那棵树不在那儿的话，然后他就像要砍掉那棵树。我妈妈说，这不是树的错。别管那棵树。你知道，但我们都有过这些时刻，我们如此，像，心烦意乱且不理智。我们就像，就是这样。是那棵树。天哪。好吧，说到树，我们那天准备好去买我们的圣诞树，我们要装饰圣诞树。我不记得发生了什么。就像某件事。那是前一天晚上。我对李说，我说，所以我们明天一大早起床。我们要去买我们的树。我们明天要装饰树。他非常随意地说，嗯，我不知道。我的意思是明天还是改天。我说，什么？明天早上9点。我就像，我像个烂摊子。
I was like, screaming and yelling. And he sat there and then he looked at me and he said, babe, is it really about the tree or is something else going on? And then I was like, oh, yeah. It was that the tree was the one Christmas tradition that I knew we could do in a pandemic. I could still put a tree in my house and I could decorate it and we could drink hot chocolate. I couldn't do any of the other gatherings or parties or seeing of people or seeing my family. family. All of my gift exchanges turned into Zoom exchanges. And I had been holding on to this tradition of putting on Christmas music and decorating our tree. And the idea that we might not do it on that
我就像，尖叫和咆哮。他坐在那里，然后他看着我说，宝贝，这真的是关于树吗，还是发生了别的事情？然后我说，哦，是的。那是树是我知道我们可以在大流行期间做的唯一圣诞传统。我仍然可以在我的房子里放一棵树，我可以装饰它，我们可以喝热巧克力。我不能做任何其他的聚会或派对，或者见人，或者见我的家人。我所有的礼物交换都变成了Zoom交换。我一直坚持着放圣诞音乐和装饰我们的树这个传统。而我们可能不会在那天做这件事的想法
Saturday, but maybe we'd do it Sunday. I was like, I had a real, real big reaction. Yeah. So guess what? We got our tree that next day at 9 a.m. Well, we went ahead and got it because Lee was like, We clearly need to get this woman a tree. Well, my dad cut down a few limbs off that tree. Oh, no. To clear the driveway, he said, even though we all know it's because he didn't measure and he pulled into the carport and he dented in the top of it. So we've all been Michael. We've all been Michael, you guys.
周六，但也许我们周日做。我就像，我有一个非常，非常大的反应。是的。所以猜猜怎么着？我们第二天早上9点就买了我们的树。好吧，我们继续买了它，因为李说，我们显然需要给这个女人买一棵树。好吧，我爸爸从那棵树上砍下了一些树枝。哦，不。为了清理车道，他说，尽管我们都知道这是因为他没有测量，他开进了车棚，把顶部撞凹了。所以我们都当过迈克尔。我们都当过迈克尔，伙计们。
And, and yeah, and it's going to get worse before it gets better. Well, yeah. Dwight and Michael go into the conference room and they confront this pizza guy. Yeah, kid. It's a kid. He's a teenager. And they're sort of like interrogating him. He doesn't own the company. He doesn't set the prices. And he that he, listen, the pizza guy is just like, you guys can kiss my ass. Like, he's not having it. Well, we had to ask Kevin what it was like to do these scenes with Stephen Rayne interrogating him because they are being so ridiculous. And guys, here's what Kevin had to say. It was definitely one of my first jobs. It was absolutely without question. The big. job I had ever done, even though it was just one episode. It was on one of the biggest TV shows in the world. And I just remember more than anything, obviously, I was very nervous and scared to work with Steve,
而且，是的，在好转之前情况会变得更糟。好吧，是的。德怀特和迈克尔走进会议室，他们与这个披萨送货员对质。是的，孩子。是个孩子。他是个青少年。他们有点像在审问他。他不拥有这家公司。他不设定价格。他，听着，披萨送货员就像，你们可以亲我的屁股。就像，他不吃这一套。好吧，我们不得不问凯文和斯蒂芬·雷恩审问他是什么感觉，因为他们太荒谬了。伙计们，这就是凯文要说的。这绝对是我第一份工作之一。毫无疑问。我做过的最大的工作，即使它只是一集。它是在世界上最伟大的电视节目之一上。我记得最清楚的是，显然，我很紧张，害怕和史蒂夫一起工作，
but it was just as, I was just as nervous to work with everybody else because there's something about, one, I think I was 17 years old. I was the only kid. Everyone else was, you know, a fully realized person. And I feel like I had tricked everybody into letting me get on the show. And everybody was just so good, and I did not understand how they could keep a straight face. And Rain Wilson and Steve would ad lib the craziest, craziest stuff. And I, you know, locked in a room and Rain would just be yelling at me.
但我同样紧张和所有人一起工作，因为有些事情，第一，我想我当时17岁。我是唯一的孩子。其他人都是，你知道，一个完全成熟的人。我觉得我骗了所有人让我参加这个节目。每个人都太好了，我不明白他们怎么能保持严肃的表情。雷恩·威尔逊和史蒂夫会即兴发挥最疯狂，最疯狂的东西。我，你知道，被锁在一个房间里，雷恩会对我大喊大叫。
And watching it back, I'm frowning almost every scene I'm in because that was my only way to stop from breaking. and that was the only thing I really remember in terms of working with them specifically because I was just trying not to break because they're obviously comedic geniuses. That's very funny. And he's 17 in this scene, you guys. Yeah, I would not have that kind of composure at 17. I'm so impressed by that. No, I mean, I was 30 years old when I got my job as Pam on the office.
回看它，我在我参与的几乎每一幕中都在皱眉，因为那是阻止我笑场的唯一方法。那是我真正记得的关于与他们具体工作的事情，因为我只是试图不笑场，因为他们显然是喜剧天才。这太搞笑了。他在这一幕中17岁，伙计们。是的，我在17岁时不会有那种镇定。我对此印象深刻。不，我的意思是，我30岁时得到了我在《办公室》里饰演帕姆的工作。
I couldn't imagine if I had been 17 years old and paired with someone like Steve Correll and Rain Wilson in those scenes. I couldn't have done it. I know. I know. Same. Well, now, you know, Angela interrupts sort of Dwight's interrogation. She comes in very matter-of-factly and says,
我无法想象如果我17岁，在这些场景中与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔和雷恩·威尔逊这样的人搭档。我做不到。我知道。我知道。我也是。好吧，现在，你知道，安吉拉打断了德怀特的审问。她非常实事求是地走进来，说，
I have to hang these. I mean, because if she didn't hang those two blue spirals. Yeah. Yeah. What would happen? And she literally walks in holding two little blue spirally decorative things. That's it. But she has to come in.
我必须挂这些。我的意思是，因为如果她不挂那两个蓝色螺旋。是的。是的。会发生什么？她真的走进来，手里拿着两个蓝色的小螺旋装饰物。就是这样。但她必须进来。
She has to hang them. Yeah. Yeah. And it's going to take her all of 45 seconds. But Dwight looks at her longingly and the pizza guy's like, why are you looking at her like that? He's such a punk. I love this kid. Well, now there's a scene coming up, Angela, that I love because Kevin is going to have a moment where he takes.
她必须挂它们。是的。是的。这会花她整整45秒。但德怀特渴望地看着她，披萨送货员就像，你为什么那样看着她？他真是个混蛋。我喜欢这个孩子。好吧，现在有一幕要来了，安吉拉，我喜欢，因为凯文要有一个时刻，他采取了
charge. He's hungry. He is. He walks into Michael's office and he says, listen, everyone is hungry and we would like to make a request that we order the good pizza so that we can eat it while we're waiting for the hostage negotiation over the bad pizza to end. I mean, this is the most sort of. Yes. Have we ever seen Kevin take a stand before? I feel like the time we really see who Kevin is outside of the office is when he plays poker with his hat and drums and clearly when it comes to pizza. Yeah, strong feelings. Strong feelings. Well, let's take a break because when we come back, the party is in full swing.
行动。他饿了。他是。他走进迈克尔的办公室说，听着，每个人都饿了，我们想提出一个请求，我们订购好的披萨，这样我们可以在等待关于坏披萨的人质谈判结束时吃它。我的意思是，这是最某种。是的。我们以前见过凯文采取立场吗？我觉得我们真正看到凯文在办公室之外是谁的时候，是他和他的帽子和鼓玩扑克的时候，显然是在披萨方面。是的，强烈的感受。强烈的感受。好吧，让我们休息一下，因为当我们回来时，派对正在全面展开。
Yeah. Who's that woman from the other office who's going to judge Angela's party? Oh, Denise Stimms and Buffalo. I don't know. Damn you. Damn you, Denise. All right. We'll be back.
是的。那个来自另一个办公室要评判安吉拉派对的女人是谁？哦，布法罗的丹妮丝·斯蒂姆斯。我不知道。该死，丹妮丝。好吧。我们会回来的。
Well, we're back in the conference room. The party is underway. Angela really wishes she had just had one more hour. One more hour to hang more blue thingsies. Yeah. And possibly get, you know, some dancers or something. Meredith says she thinks it looks good. Meredith is so nice to Angela in this moment.
好吧，我们回到了会议室。派对正在进行中。安吉拉真的希望她能再有一个小时。再有一个小时来挂更多的蓝色小东西。是的。并且可能得到，你知道，一些舞者什么的。梅雷迪思说她认为它看起来不错。梅雷迪思在这一刻对安吉拉太好了。
Yeah. She's trying to build it. her up. She's like, I think it looks great. And Angela just was like, well, that describes the lot. I don't know what she says. Angela says, well, that's why you're never in charge of these things. So snarky. So sassy and snarky. So uncalled for. This is why no one is nice to Angela, by the way. You have given me grief. Why doesn't Pam help Angela? Why isn't Pam nicer to Angela? Because anytime anyone tries to be nice to Angela, Angela sasses them. Well, isn't it? and Angela just having her moment here, her moment of cutting down the tree branches.
是的。她试图建立它。她就像，我认为它看起来很棒。安吉拉只是说，嗯，这描述了那批货。我不知道她说了什么。安吉拉说，嗯，这就是为什么你从来不负责这些事情。太刻薄了。太傲慢和刻薄了。太没必要了。顺便说一句，这就是为什么没有人对安吉拉好。你给了我悲伤。为什么帕姆不帮助安吉拉？为什么帕姆不对安吉拉好一点？因为每当有人试图对安吉拉好时，安吉拉就会对他们刻薄。好吧，不是吗？安吉拉在这里有她的时刻，她砍掉树枝的时刻。
She is upset and she's going to take it out on Meredith. But then, Andy's got a surprise. Andy walks in, rolls in, I should say, this humongous ice sculpture. And you guys, it was huge in real life. In real life, it was enormous. I don't know if it really does it justice, like on TV watching it. It was so big. It was two swans kissing in the shape of a heart.
她很心烦，她要把它发泄在梅雷迪思身上。但随后，安迪有一个惊喜。安迪走进来，我应该说，滚进来，这个巨大的冰雕。伙计们，它在现实生活中是巨大的。在现实生活中，它是巨大的。我不知道它是否真的像在电视上看到的那样公正。它太大了。那是两只天鹅在亲吻，形状像一颗心。
Yeah. Yeah. I remember they had a bunch of them and they had them in this big walk-in freezer on these carts. And they would have to wheel them in because they would sit there then in the background for a while and they'd have to change them out. Yes. So Phil Shea had to place an order for multiple swan heart giant ice sculptures. And you have to know that there was probably a meeting between Phil and Greg where there was a flip book of all the different ice sculptures he could order. And this is the one they settled on.
是的。是的。我记得他们有一堆，他们把它们放在这些大步入式冷冻室的推车上。他们不得不把它们推进来，因为它们会在背景中坐一会儿，他们不得不更换它们。是的。所以菲尔·谢不得不订购多个天鹅心巨型冰雕。你必须知道，菲尔和格雷格之间可能有一个会议，那里有一本他可以订购的所有不同冰雕的翻页书。这就是他们决定的那个。
A hundred percent. Well, I texted Jen Salada and I was like, Jen, what was the backstory of this ice sculpture? Like Andy says he stole it. Was there any backstory that we didn't get to see? And Jen said her idea was that Andy went into a wedding reception and stole this. that he stole it from a wedding reception. Isn't that hilarious? That explains the heart shape swan's kissing for sure.
百分之百。好吧，我给珍·萨拉达发了短信，我说，珍，这个冰雕的背景故事是什么？就像安迪说他偷了它。有什么我们没看到的背景故事吗？珍说她的想法是安迪走进一个婚礼招待会并偷了这个。他从婚礼招待会上偷了它。这不搞笑吗？这肯定解释了心形天鹅亲吻的形状。
Yeah. But I thought that was a really funny little detail. Well, listen, the virtual part of this party is about to begin. I have to say it was so crazy in this new world of Zooms and, you know, virtual meetings that we're in right now to see this web. webcam, multiple webcam party. Yeah. Because back then, this would have been just very cutting edge. Very cutting edge.
是的。但我认为那是一个非常有趣的小细节。好吧，听着，这个派对的虚拟部分即将开始。我不得不说，在这个我们现在所处的Zoom和虚拟会议的新世界里，看到这个网络摄像头，多网络摄像头派对真是太疯狂了。是的。因为那时，这本来是非常前沿的。非常前沿。
And now it's all we do. It's the only way I see you. We're doing this right now, closet to closet. That's right. Well, Pam tells Michael that Ryan is going to introduce him in a few minutes. And when that happens, they're going to cut to our conference room. and all Michael has to do is smile and wave. Yeah.
而现在这是我们所做的一切。这是我见到你的唯一方式。我们现在正在这样做，从壁橱到壁橱。没错。好吧，帕姆告诉迈克尔，瑞安几分钟后会介绍他。当这种情况发生时，他们会切到我们的会议室。迈克尔所要做的就是微笑和挥手。是的。
And Michael's like, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. You know, you know it's not going to go well. Well, in the meantime, Jim very charmingly invites Pam up on the roof. He said he's going to grab pizzas, tells her to grab some napkins and plates and stuff. And they go up on the roof and they have a rooftop dinner date. Yeah. Well, this is a callback to the client episode when Pam.
迈克尔就像，是的，是的，是的。你知道，你知道这不会顺利。好吧，与此同时，吉姆非常迷人地邀请帕姆上屋顶。他说他要去拿披萨，告诉她拿些餐巾纸和盘子什么的。他们上到屋顶，进行了一次屋顶晚餐约会。是的。好吧，这是对《客户》那一集的呼应，当帕姆。
Pam and Jim sneak up to the roof after they've read Threat Level Midnight and they share some grilled cheese sandwiches. Now they're going to go up and they're going to share some pizza. And they're also going to talk about when they knew that they liked the other person, right?
帕姆和吉姆在读完《威胁等级午夜》后溜到屋顶，他们分享了一些烤奶酪三明治。现在他们要上去分享一些披萨。他们还要谈论他们什么时候知道他们喜欢对方，对吧？
Because now they're dating. Now they're not these star-cross lovers. Now they're actually a couple. And I thought that was kind of interesting to find out for sure. Pam was there first. We find that out in the scene. Yes, but then they're
因为现在他们在约会。现在他们不是这些苦命的恋人。现在他们实际上是一对。我觉得这很有趣，肯定能发现。帕姆先在那里。我们在那一幕中发现了这一点。是的，但随后他们是
other episodes where Jim talks about Pam's first day. What? It's in complete conflict. Ah, yeah. Well, here in this scene, Jim says, do you remember what you said to me on my first day of work just before you walked me over to my desk? So clearly, it's like Pam is showing him around. I know, but I'm telling you, there's another episode where Jim says I remember when Pam first came into the office. Oh, continuity error. That's a big one. That's a big story point. I like the idea personally that Pam worked there first. It makes sense to me. And I love this moment when Pam goes, yeah, I said to you, enjoy this moment because
其他剧集，吉姆谈论帕姆的第一天。什么？这完全冲突。啊，是的。好吧，在这一幕中，吉姆说，你还记得你在我工作的第一天，就在你带我走到办公桌前之前对我说了什么吗？所以很明显，就像帕姆带他四处看看。我知道，但我告诉你，还有另一集，吉姆说我记得帕姆第一次来到办公室的时候。哦，连续性错误。这是一个很大的错误。这是一个很大的故事点。我个人喜欢帕姆先在那里工作的想法。这对我来说很有意义。我喜欢帕姆说，是的，我对你说，享受这一刻，因为
you're never going to go back to this time before you met your destiny twice. And then Pam says that she knew that she liked Jim when he warned her that her mixed berry yogurt that she was about to eat was expired. And you know what? I get it. Me too. I get it because he had so just observed her, seen her, knew her. It just is such a like window into how much attention he paid to her. Well, listen, when Lee and I first started dating, there was this moment where I had moved into a new place and I wanted a grill. Speaking of grills, you were talking about your dad, that's getting his big grill. His big, yeah.
在你遇到你的命运两次之前，你永远不会回到这个时间。然后帕姆说，当吉姆警告她，她即将吃的混合浆果酸奶过期时，她就知道她喜欢吉姆。你知道吗？我明白了。我也是。我明白了，因为他如此观察她，看到她，了解她。这就像一个窗口，展示了他对她有多么关注。好吧，听着，当李和我刚开始约会时，有这样一个时刻，我搬进了一个新地方，我想要一个烤架。说到烤架，你在谈论你爸爸，他正在得到他的大烤架。他的大，是的。
So I got this grill and it needed to be assembled. And I was a little bit like, oh, but I guess I'd been talking to Lee all about how excited I was to barbecue because it would, it reminds me of home. My dad grilled a lot, you know, and he taught me how to grill. So he said, hey, how about I go over to your place while you're at work and I'll put together that grill for you and we could grill some food. when you get home from work. And I was like, really?
所以我得到了这个烤架，它需要组装。我有点像，哦，但我猜我一直在和李谈论我有多兴奋去烧烤，因为它会，它让我想起家。我爸爸经常烧烤，你知道，他教我怎么烧烤。所以他说，嘿，我下班后去你家，我帮你把那个烤架组装起来，我们可以烤些食物怎么样。当你下班回家时。我说，真的吗？
When I got home from work that day, there he was in my backyard. He had put together the grill. He had broken down the box. Oh, that's big. He had gotten rid of the... Oh, breaking down the boxes everything. Come on.
那天我下班回家时，他就在我的后院。他组装好了烤架。他拆掉了盒子。哦，那很大。他处理掉了……哦，拆掉盒子就是一切。来吧。
Come on. Getting rid of the mess. I mean, building the grill. The box was as big as me. Yeah. And then he had marinated some chicken for us to grill. That is the moment I knew. I am probably going to marry this man.
来吧。处理掉混乱。我的意思是，建造烤架。盒子和我一样大。是的。然后他腌了一些鸡肉让我们烤。那一刻我知道。我可能会嫁给这个男人。
This is amazing. And I'm sure that Lee, if he asked me and was like, what was the moment you knew? And I was like, it was that day that you broke down the box for the grill. And he was like, that was the moment. Well, listen, building a grill is no joke. I have like done that. I've assisted. And it's like building a small Cessna.
这太棒了。我相信李，如果他问我，就像，你什么时候知道的？我说，就是那天你为烤架拆掉盒子的时候。他说，就是那一刻。好吧，听着，建造一个烤架不是开玩笑的。我像做过那个。我协助过。它就像建造一架小型塞斯纳飞机。
It's so many parts. And then to break down all the mess, come on. Of course you were like, I think this one's a keeper. Yes. Listen, so I get where Pam is coming from. That is a sweet, wonderful detail of everyday life. That's intimacy. It really is that he tracks her yogurt.
它有这么多零件。然后处理掉所有的混乱，来吧。当然你就像，我想这个是一个守护者。是的。听着，所以我明白帕姆来自哪里。那是日常生活的一个甜蜜、美妙的细节。那是亲密关系。他追踪她的酸奶，这确实是。
It's adorable. Well, I had a really long drive for work. I had a long commute coming up. And Josh dropped off a mixed CD of music because I was saying I didn't have a lot in my music library. I'm really bad about that, you guys. Like, I'll hear a song and like it, but I don't ever put it in a playlist and then music's all over the place. It probably, actually, as I say it, you're probably like, Angela, this sounds very own brand. Like, if I could write all the songs I like on 100 different post-it notes.
这很可爱。好吧，我上班有很长的车程。我有一个很长的通勤路程。乔什留下了一张混合音乐CD，因为我说我的音乐库里没有太多东西。我真的很糟糕，伙计们。就像，我会听到一首歌并喜欢它，但我从来没有把它放在播放列表中，然后音乐到处都是。它可能，实际上，当我这么说时，你可能就像，安吉拉，这听起来非常符合品牌。就像，如果我能把我喜欢的所有歌写在100张不同的便利贴上。
But Josh made me this driving playlist for my long commute. And I was like, that is so stinking thoughtful. Yeah. Guys out there, it's the little things. Yeah. we like that stuff break down a box and make a make a playlist you're in if you want to like really get your wife turned on oh lord here we go take out the trash without being asked take it out before it's overflowing do you know what i mean take it out before you've like tried to cram it back
但乔什为我漫长的通勤制作了这个驾驶播放列表。我当时想，那真是太贴心了。是的。外面的伙计们，这是小事。是的。我们喜欢那种东西，拆掉一个盒子，制作一个播放列表，如果你想，像，真正让你妻子兴奋，哦，天哪，我们开始吧，在没有被要求的情况下倒垃圾，在它溢出之前倒掉它。你知道我的意思吗？在它像试图把它塞回去之前倒掉它
in that's right and then pour her a glass of wine and like subtly walk her past the empty trash can and you're in telling you if you want to land a lady like me or Angela take out the trash without being asked and you got us or notice the new bath mat that I bought and be like oh my gosh babe did you get a new bath mat I love it it's fantastic I'm like I'm like like baum chica baum bow or how about this you know what those extra christmas seasonal pillows that you had to have really made the place feel homie oh oh my gosh yes you notice my seasonal pillows bianch bam bam bam bam guys we're telling you write us try one of these things and then you write us about the night you had because it's on well give us the overview of the night you had.
在，没错，然后给她倒一杯酒，像微妙地带她走过空的垃圾桶，你就进去了。告诉你，如果你想赢得像我或安吉拉这样的女士，在没有被要求的情况下倒垃圾，你就得到了我们，或者注意到我买的新浴垫，就像，哦，天哪，宝贝，你买了一个新浴垫吗？我喜欢它，它太棒了。我就像，我就像，像砰，砰，砰，或者这个怎么样，你知道那些你必须拥有的额外的圣诞季节性枕头真的让这个地方感觉很温馨，哦，天哪，是的，你注意到了我的季节性枕头，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，伙计们，我们告诉你们，写信给我们，尝试这些事情中的一件，然后写信告诉我们你度过的那个夜晚，因为它在，好吧，给我们一个你度过的夜晚的概述。
Just tell us, it worked. I don't need all the details, Jenna. No, I don't want the details. Please, no unsolicited picks. Oh, my God. Who's asking for pictures? Now you've put that in their brain. Pictures of what?
只要告诉我们，它奏效了。我不需要所有的细节，珍娜。不，我不想知道细节。请，没有未经请求的照片。哦，天哪。谁在要照片？现在你把它放进他们的脑子里了。什么照片？
They're night. That's inappropriate. That's why I'm saying. Don't send them. I don't want photos. I don't want details. Just tell me, oh, my God, you guys, it worked. Okay.
他们的夜晚。那是不合适的。这就是我说的。不要发送它们。我不想要照片。我不想要细节。只要告诉我，哦，天哪，你们，它奏效了。好吧。
So now the party is really underway. And we see a little bit of a callback to a character at 32 minutes 58 seconds. We see Dan Gore, the original manager. He's back. And now we're coming up to the point where Scranton is going to get its shout out, right? This is what Michael says. He says, hey, I just think you should know one of my salesmen beat your stupid computer. So take that asshole. Yeah. And then Kelly takes her pizza and smashes it onto Ryan's face on the TV screen. That's Scranton's moment in this corporate event. But wait, then the pizza kid runs up to the webcam and says that he's a minor being held
所以现在派对真的在进行了。我们在32分58秒看到对一个角色的一个小呼应。我们看到了丹·戈尔，最初的经理。他回来了。现在我们要来到斯克兰顿要得到它的呼喊的地方，对吧？这就是迈克尔说的。他说，嘿，我觉得你应该知道，我的一个推销员打败了你们愚蠢的电脑。所以拿着那个混蛋。是的。然后凯莉拿着她的披萨，把它砸在电视屏幕上瑞安的脸上。那是斯克兰顿在这个企业活动中的时刻。但等等，然后披萨小子跑到网络摄像头前说他是一个未成年人，被扣押
against his will. Yes. How does anyone in this branch still have a job? I don't know. I don't know. But meanwhile, just as all of this is going on, Andy tries to scratch Angela's back. Andy, what are your moves? Tell me, what are your moves to, like, get a lady interested in you? First, you have ridiculous pickup lines, like the movie in the box, and then you go up to someone
违背他的意愿。是的。这个分部的任何人怎么还有工作？我不知道。我不知道。但与此同时，就在所有这一切发生的时候，安迪试图抓安吉拉的背。安迪，你的动作是什么？告诉我，你的动作是什么，像，让一个女士对你感兴趣？首先，你有荒谬的搭讪语，比如盒子里的电影，然后你走到某人身边
you don't really know and scratch their back. Are you crazy? Well, she said she had an itch she couldn't reach. She did, but I don't think that was an invitation. No. Yeah, that wasn't an invitation, Andy. Don't go scratching people's backs unless you're invited to scratch their back. And Angela definitely does not seem interested. And then there's a scene, Jenna, that I love. It's something our show does that I love. It's never explained. It's just Dwight and Andy standing outside the men's room. Dwight is clearly on guard by his whole physical posture. So we're just left to assume pizza guys in there on his bathroom break. He's been led in there. And Andy and Dwight have this whole conversation outside the men's room. And at one point, Dwight kicks open the door
你不真正认识的人，抓他们的背。你疯了吗？好吧，她说她有一个她够不到的痒。她确实有，但我不认为那是一个邀请。不。是的，那不是一个邀请，安迪。除非你被邀请抓他们的背，否则不要去抓别人的背。安吉拉绝对看起来不感兴趣。然后有一幕，珍娜，我喜欢。这是我们的节目做的一件我喜欢的事情。它从未被解释。只是德怀特和安迪站在男厕所外面。德怀特显然通过他整个身体姿势在守卫。所以我们只是假设披萨小子在里面进行他的厕所休息。他被带进去了。安迪和德怀特在男厕所外面进行了整个对话。在某一点，德怀特踢开了门
and says, unless you're going number two, you've got about 15 seconds left or something to that effect. And I just have to say, I really loved Rain's choice here. Like the way he kicked the door, he looked very official. He did. And Rain, I feel like his performance in the scene is so great. It's all these little moments. He's slightly like, please. right that Angela has rejected Andy he's still crestfallen he's still upset that Andy wants to continue to pursue her but yet he has a job to do and that is to make sure the pizza guy doesn't escape well the Dwight character is such a great character because he is so invested and committed to being Michael's number two so much so that in a
说，除非你要上二号，否则你还剩下大约15秒左右的时间。我不得不说，我真的很喜欢雷恩在这里的选择。就像他踢门的方式，他看起来非常正式。他确实。雷恩，我觉得他在这一幕中的表演太棒了。这都是这些小时刻。他稍微有点，请。对，安吉拉拒绝了安迪，他仍然垂头丧气，他仍然对安迪想要继续追求她感到不安，但他有一份工作要做，那就是确保披萨小子不会逃跑。好吧，德怀特这个角色是一个非常棒的角色，因为他如此投入和致力于成为迈克尔的二号人物，以至于在
minute he's going to be interrogating this pizza kid and Michael is now going to going to suddenly realize what they've done, that they have kidnapped someone. And he starts freaking out. And it takes Dwight a second because he was so committed to the other choice. But then he becomes just as committed to the new choice. And he pays for all the pizza. Yeah. He's so loyal to Michael. And it is a little bit like creepy. It's, it reminded me a little bit of like Lord of the Flies. Like, you know, it's like all of a sudden, you know, when people follow someone who they shouldn't be following and then where does that lead them and what are they capable of? What was Dwight going to continue to do to this pizza guy? Well, it's such a
一分钟后，他将审问这个披萨小子，迈克尔现在将突然意识到他们做了什么，他们绑架了某人。他开始惊慌失措。这花了一秒钟，因为他太致力于另一个选择了。但他随后变得同样致力于新的选择。他支付了所有的披萨。是的。他对迈克尔如此忠诚。这有点像令人毛骨悚然。它，它让我想起了一点像《蝇王》。就像，你知道，它就像突然，你知道，当人们跟随一个他们不应该跟随的人时，那会把他们引向哪里，他们能做什么？德怀特还要继续对这个披萨小子做什么？好吧，这是一个如此
crazy storyline. We talked about it and I feel like so much of it really hinges on Kevin's great performance. Yes, I absolutely agree. He was perfect all throughout the scenes. Yeah. And we just asked him if he had any memories from his time on the show. And here's what he had to say. my biggest memory or takeaway from the entire experience period was honestly the generosity and the kindness from everybody everybody went out of their way to accept me to welcome me with open arms I sat with you know a lot of the cast for lunch every day I think they you know I was totally a fish out of water and I think everybody could see that and it's one of those things where you come on set they welcome you to set in rehearsal and everybody cheers. And that is something that I've taken with me, and I remember going into
疯狂的故事情节。我们谈论了它，我觉得它很大程度上取决于凯文出色的表演。是的，我完全同意。他在整个场景中都很完美。是的。我们只是问他是否有任何关于他在节目中时间的记忆。这就是他要说的。我整个经历期间最大的记忆或收获，老实说，是每个人的慷慨和善良，每个人都竭尽全力接受我，张开双臂欢迎我，我每天和，你知道，很多演员一起吃午饭，我想他们，你知道，我完全是一个离开水的鱼，我想每个人都能看到这一点，这是那种你来到片场，他们在排练时欢迎你来到片场，每个人都欢呼的事情。这是我随身携带的东西，我记得进入
Glee, how it hit me at some point of like, oh, I'm now in their position as a person who's on this show every week. And when people come on, I need to treat them how the office people treated me. And whenever I would see people, see Kate, I would see Mindy out at events or whatever it may be, and everyone was just still so nice to me, and they'd come up and be like, oh, I'm so happy, like, the Glee is doing so well. And it was one of those things where me coming on to a show that was so big and all these people were so very famous and successful that even though I was now on a show that was successful, I still felt very much like the fan. And the fact that they could come up to me and they just always treated me with kindness and as an equal. And
《欢乐合唱团》，它在某个时刻击中了我，就像，哦，我现在处于他们的位置，作为一个每周都在这个节目上的人。当人们来的时候，我需要像《办公室》的人对待我那样对待他们。每当我看到人们，看到凯特，看到明迪在活动中，或者无论它可能是什么，每个人仍然对我很好，他们会走过来，就像，哦，我太高兴了，像，《欢乐合唱团》做得这么好。这是那种我来到一个如此大的节目，所有这些人如此出名和成功，即使我现在在一个成功的节目上，我仍然感觉非常像粉丝的事情。他们能走过来，他们总是以善良和平等的态度对待我，而且
that's something I will never ever forget. And I say they, but I realize it's you, you guys. So thanks for being so nice. You know, lady, it's so sweet for him to say that. And it really takes me back because when I was an aspiring actor and I would get those guest star roles on shows, it would be such a big deal to me. But I would go on the set and I would feel just so alone. And most of the time, people, people didn't invite me to eat lunch with them. And they were in their own world because they had that job every day so it wasn't particularly special to them. And I would just feel, you know, like I was really on my own. We've talked about it, like a kid in a new school on the first day of school. Yeah. With all the pressure of like the new day and the new place and the new work and all of it. Yeah. And people did not generally go out of their way to try to make me feel better. And that was fine. But I think all of us on the office had been knocking around for so long and had experienced that feeling so many times that whenever we did have a guest star, I would watch as everyone would go out of their way to introduce themselves, say hello, shake hands, invite that person to eat lunch with them, show them where the craft services was. I do have this memory of us just being so hospitable. It was like, welcome to our house. Let's show you around, give you a tour.
那是我永远都不会忘记的事情。我说“他们”，但我意识到其实是你们，你们大家。所以谢谢你们这么友善。你知道吗，女士，他能这么说真是太贴心了。这真的让我回想起过去，因为当我还是个怀揣梦想的演员，在节目中获得那些客串角色时，那对我来说是一件大事。但我到了片场，却感到非常孤独。大多数时候，人们并没有邀请我一起吃午饭。他们沉浸在自己的世界里，因为他们每天都有那份工作，所以对他们来说这并不特别。我只会觉得，你知道，我真的是孤身一人。我们谈论过这个，就像第一天上学的新生一样。是的。伴随着新的一天、新的环境、新的工作以及所有这一切带来的压力。是的。人们通常不会特意去让我感觉好受些。那也没关系。但我认为我们《办公室》剧组的所有人都在这一行摸爬滚打太久了，经历过太多次那种感觉，所以每当我们有客串明星时，我都会看着大家特意去自我介绍、打招呼、握手、邀请那个人一起吃午饭，带他们去茶点区。我确实记得我们当时是多么好客。就像是，欢迎来到我们的家。让我们带你四处看看，给你做个导览。
Do you know where the bathrooms are? And I think it was because all of us had been around for so long, experiencing it the other way that we wanted our show to be different. And we just did it. We never talked about it. It was just this collective thing that we all did. Yeah. And you definitely remember with each job,
你知道洗手间在哪里吗？我想这是因为我们所有人都已经在这一行待了太久，经历过那种被冷落的感觉，所以我们希望我们的剧组能有所不同。我们就是这么做了。我们从未讨论过这件事。这只是我们所有人共同做的一件事。是的。而且你肯定会记得每一份工作，
especially when you're starting out if there was one person that showed you kindness. You just like remember it and you hold on to it. And I'm so glad that our show was like that for Kevin, you know, and that he took that same philosophy to glee with him. Yeah, that's really cool. Well, we also asked him if he, after all this time, still gets recognized as the pizza guy from the office,
尤其是当你刚起步的时候，如果有一个人对你表现出善意。你只会记得它并铭记在心。我很高兴我们的剧组对凯文来说就是那样，你知道，而且他把同样的理念带到了《欢乐合唱团》。是的，那真的很酷。好吧，我们还问他，过了这么久，他是否还会因为《办公室》里的披萨小哥而被认出来，
even though he's gone on to all these other amazing projects, and here is what he had to say about that. The amount of times I get recognized for the office is mind-boggling, truly. Like, even in the midst of Glee, even after Glee, I get recognized a solid quarter of the time from the office from one single episode. I did 120-something episodes of Glee, but the one episode I did of the office, I get recognized that much. And it's absolutely a different demographic. And you can always tell. But it's still just surprising because I also, I think I look pretty different.
尽管他已经参与了所有其他精彩的项目，以下是他对此的看法。我因为《办公室》被认出来的次数多得令人难以置信，真的。比如，即使在《欢乐合唱团》期间，甚至在《欢乐合唱团》之后，我被认出来的情况中，有四分之一是因为《办公室》里那唯一的一集。我拍了120多集《欢乐合唱团》，但我拍的那一集《办公室》，我被认出来的频率竟然那么高。而且这绝对是不同的人群。你总是能分辨出来。但这仍然令人惊讶，因为我也觉得我看起来很不一样。
That was almost 15 years ago. So I'm always baffled. And it sort of makes me feel very proud every time. Yeah, that's right. I was on that show once. Well, you know, four days. I love it. I love it.
那已经是快15年前的事了。所以我总是感到困惑。而且每次都让我感到非常自豪。是的，没错。我曾经在那部剧里出现过一次。好吧，你知道，四天。我喜欢这样。我喜欢这样。
Well, I'm glad he had such a great experience on the show. And I like that the legacy has endured for him. Let us tell you where you can find Kevin. On Instagram, he is just his full name, Kevin McH-A-L-E. That's Kevin M-C-H-A-L-E. And on Twitter, he is Druid-D-R-U-D-E. Well, now, Angela, we have my other favorite scene from this episode coming up with you in it again. I love that scene with you and Michael where he's giving you all of the instructions.
好吧，我很高兴他在剧组有这么棒的经历。而且我喜欢这种遗产对他来说一直延续着。让我们告诉你们在哪里可以找到凯文。在Instagram上，他就是他的全名，Kevin McH-A-L-E。那是Kevin M-C-H-A-L-E。在Twitter上，他是Druid-D-R-U-D-E。好了，现在，安吉拉，我们要播放这一集中我最喜欢的另一个场景，你也在里面。我喜欢你和迈克尔的那场戏，他给了你所有的指示。
and I love when Andy comes over to serenade Angela over speakerphone with his Acapella Pals. This was so, did you say Acapella Pells? Acapella Pals. Acapella Pals. His Acapella Pals. His Acapella Pals. Aca what?
我喜欢安迪过来用免提电话为安吉拉献唱，伴随着他的“阿卡贝拉伙伴们”。这是，你是说“阿卡贝拉佩尔们”吗？阿卡贝拉伙伴们。阿卡贝拉伙伴们。他的阿卡贝拉伙伴们。他的阿卡贝拉伙伴们。阿卡什么？
My Acapella Pals. Yeah. This scene was so much fun to do. And, oh my gosh. More went into it than. then you'll know. I mean, it was pretty like a tech heavy moment. Oh, for sure. Well, we actually asked Jen, how did she come up with this idea for the serenade or how did she pitch this idea? Because this was brilliant and so charming. And here's what she had to say. I remember pitching to
我的阿卡贝拉伙伴们。是的。这场戏拍起来太有趣了。而且，天哪。投入的精力比你们知道的要多。我的意思是，这算是一个技术含量很高的时刻。哦，当然。好吧，我们实际上问了简，她是怎么想出这个小夜曲的点子的，或者她是怎么推销这个点子的？因为这太精彩、太迷人了。以下是她的话。我记得向
Greg that Andy could sing, take a chance on me to Angela with speakerphone backup singers. And Greg was like, cool, cool, go tell Ed so we can start thinking about how he'd want to sing it. And I walked down to Ed's trailer and I'm just awkward in general, but then also I had a bit of a fan girl thing because I loved Ed on The Daily Show and I was still so excited that he was on the office. So I just awkwardly knocked on his trailer door and told him, hey, we're thinking about having Andy sing, take a chance on me to Angela. And we just wanted you to start thinking about the song. He's like, what song? I said, take a chance on me, Mama Mia, Abba. And he didn't know the song.
格雷格提议，安迪可以唱《Take a Chance on Me》给安吉拉听，并配上免提电话里的伴唱。格雷格说，酷，酷，去告诉埃德，这样我们就可以开始考虑他想怎么唱了。我走到埃德的拖车前，我平时就很笨拙，但当时我还有点小粉丝心态，因为我喜欢《每日秀》里的埃德，而且我仍然为他能出演《办公室》感到兴奋。所以我笨拙地敲了敲他的拖车门，告诉他，嘿，我们想让安迪唱《Take a Chance on Me》给安吉拉听。我们只是想让你开始考虑这首歌。他说，什么歌？我说，《Take a Chance on Me》，《妈妈咪呀》，ABBA乐队的。他不知道这首歌。
And I'm thinking, oh, God, how can you not know the song? Maybe slightly predicting the horror that was about to come. And he's like, how does it go? And I am a terrible singer. I cannot sing at all. And so I was like, oh, you know, it's like, remember Mamma Mia? And did you know the song? And I just tried to figure out how to say it without singing it.
我在想，天哪，你怎么可能不知道这首歌？也许稍微预示了即将到来的恐怖。他说，这首歌怎么唱？我是一个糟糕的歌手。我根本不会唱歌。所以我说，哦，你知道，就像，记得《妈妈咪呀》吗？你知道这首歌吗？我只是试图想办法在不唱出来的情况下说清楚。
And then we ended up walking around the parking lot. And I had to sing, take a chance on me to Edge. And it was so embarrassing, but so lovely. He was so wonderful about it. And I love that scene so much. I just thought he killed it and was so excited that he was able to do such a fantastic job with it. It was just exciting. That would be me.
然后我们最后在停车场走来走去。我不得不对着埃德唱《Take a Chance on Me》。这太尴尬了，但也太可爱了。他对此表现得非常棒。我非常喜欢那场戏。我只是觉得他演得太棒了，而且很高兴他能做得这么出色。这真是令人兴奋。那会是我。
I'd be so nervous if all of a sudden I had to sing something to someone because I hate singing in front of people. I love to belt it out, you know, at home in the shower or like just in the kitchen with the kids. But if I had to like, you know, oh my God, like have someone like Ed or like Steve or someone be like, okay, how does that go? I'd be so nervous and embarrassed. Well, we also got a lot of fan questions from Jen Reynolds, Sarah Thorup, Stephen Jackson, Roxanne Hoffman, and Becca Harrington. They wanted to know who sang the backup on the telephone for Andy. How was that accomplished? Were they actually on the line or was it pre-recorded? Oh, Jenna, my memory is we did that in real time. And I'll tell you why, because I had to be there reacting and I thought, whatever
如果我突然不得不给某人唱歌，我会非常紧张，因为我讨厌在别人面前唱歌。我喜欢在家里洗澡时，或者只是在厨房和孩子们在一起时大声唱出来。但如果我不得不，你知道，天哪，让像埃德或史蒂夫这样的人说，好吧，那首歌怎么唱？我会非常紧张和尴尬。好吧，我们还收到了很多粉丝的问题，来自简·雷诺兹、莎拉·索鲁普、斯蒂芬·杰克逊、罗克珊·霍夫曼和贝卡·哈林顿。他们想知道是谁在电话里为安迪伴唱。这是怎么完成的？他们真的在线上吗，还是预先录制好的？哦，珍娜，我的记忆是我们是实时完成的。我告诉你们为什么，因为我必须在那里做出反应，我想，无论
you do, Angela, you cannot mess this up for these guys, you know? Like, because they had it all timed out and we actually asked Jen Salada about it. And this is what she had to. say. One of the singers we were so lucky to get for the acapella take a chance on me was John Michael Higgins. You'll know him from Christopher Guest movies. He's just brilliant. And so we were super, super excited. I don't know who the other singer was. So I tried to track it down and I was unsuccessful. We, I believe we recorded it on the day in that John and whoever else maybe besides John, we're in the little office that the writers used to hang out on set. And they called in and sang through the speaker phones.
你做什么，安吉拉，你不能为这些人搞砸了，你知道吗？因为他们把时间都算好了，我们实际上问了简·萨拉达。这就是她要说的。我们很幸运能请到约翰·迈克尔·希金斯为《Take a Chance on Me》做阿卡贝拉伴唱。你们会从克里斯托弗·盖斯特的电影中认识他。他真是太天才了。所以我们超级超级兴奋。我不知道另一位歌手是谁。所以我试图追踪，但没有成功。我相信我们是在当天录制的，约翰和除了约翰之外的其他人，在编剧们平时在片场待的小办公室里。他们打进电话，通过免提电话唱了出来。
And then I'm sure we recorded a clean version two of it, not through the speaker phones, so that we could have it in the mix and then just make sure that we got the sound quality great. But it was a really fun day. I just thought that they killed it. Well, I remember that, Angela, because I remember listening. to Ed and those guys practicing before they divided up and went into the sort of speakerphone situation. Right, right. But it was a big deal.
然后我肯定我们也录了一个干净的版本，不是通过免提电话的，这样我们就可以把它混音进去，确保音质很好。但那真是非常有趣的一天。我只是觉得他们唱得太棒了。好吧，我记得那个，安吉拉，因为我记得听着埃德和那些家伙在他们分开并进入那种免提电话状态之前练习。对，对。但这确实是一件大事。
And what a big get for just this voice on the phone that has gone completely uncredited. I know. And I am such a fan of Johns. Like he is such a comedic genius. And he and Ed and how they put this all together and did it was so fantastic. I loved every second of it. It was hard for me not to fully smile because it was so charming and delightful.
对于这个电话里的声音来说，这真是一个巨大的收获，而且完全没有署名。我知道。我是约翰的超级粉丝。他真是个喜剧天才。他和埃德，以及他们如何把这一切组合在一起并完成它，真是太棒了。我喜欢其中的每一秒。我很难不完全笑出来，因为它太迷人、太令人愉悦了。
And you know, Angela's trying not to tip her hand too much. She only has a very slight smile at like one or two parts, right? Yep. But I just, I have such fond memories of this. And I just felt like we had to hear it. If you change your mind, I'll be first in line. Honey, I'm still free, take a chance on me. If you need me, let me know.
而且你知道，安吉拉试图不表现得太明显。她只有在一两个地方露出了非常轻微的微笑，对吧？是的。但我只是，我有关于这个的美好回忆。我觉得我们必须听听它。如果你改变主意，我会排在第一位。亲爱的，我还单身，给我一个机会。如果你需要我，让我知道。
Gonna be around. If you got no place to go, if you're feeling down. If you're all alone, when the pretty birds have flown. Honey, I'm still free. Take a chance on me. Gonna do my very best, and that ain't no lie. If you put me to the test, if you let me try, take a chance on me.
我会一直在。如果你没地方去，如果你感到沮丧。如果你孤身一人，当美丽的鸟儿飞走时。亲爱的，我还单身。给我一个机会。我会尽我所能，那绝不是谎言。如果你考验我，如果你让我尝试，给我一个机会。
That's all I ask of you, Angela. I mean, come on, how they harmonized at the end like that. All right, I got goosebumps listening to that. I got a little choked up. I don't know if I just miss Ed a lot and he's so charming in this scene. Or if it's just the time we're in, I don't know. I've also just fallen in love with Andy during this rewatch. You know, we've talked about how I have this new appreciation for Ryan.
这就是我对你的全部要求，安吉拉。我的意思是，拜托，他们最后那样的和声。好吧，听着那个我起鸡皮疙瘩了。我有点哽咽了。我不知道是因为我太想念埃德了，他在这一幕里太迷人了。还是因为我们所处的时代，我不知道。在这次重温中，我也爱上了安迪。你知道，我们谈论过我对瑞安有了新的欣赏。
But I also just have been loving the character of Andy in his journey. But I don't know, Angela. I also have to say, I know I mentioned that the weight of my heart is to put together a grill and break down the box. But I think that if there was a guy that I actually was not that interested in, if he did this, I would be like, okay. All right. It is so sweet. It's so, so charming. You know, my husband is a really good singer, and he doesn't really sing around people.
但我同时也一直很喜欢安迪这个角色和他的旅程。但我不知道，安吉拉。我也必须说，我知道我提到过我心里的重担是组装一个烤架并拆掉盒子。但我想，如果有一个我其实没那么感兴趣的男人，如果他做了这件事，我会觉得，好吧。好吧。这太甜了。太迷人了。你知道，我丈夫是个很好的歌手，他其实不在别人面前唱歌。
But when we first started dating, we went out and there was karaoke, and I didn't really know the side of him. He's like an a cappella guy. and he got up and sang Journey and he brought down the bar and I was like oh my gosh that's a my back but it was just so
但当我们刚开始约会时，我们出去玩，那里有卡拉OK，我真的不知道他这一面。他是个阿卡贝拉爱好者。他站起来唱了《Journey》，他把酒吧的气氛推向了高潮，我当时想，天哪，那真是太棒了，但它就是那么
so sweet in this moment Andy you know and Andy will go on to sing to Angela again but you know he must really like her if he's going to bust out the Acapella group yeah he's all in
在这一刻太甜了，安迪，你知道，安迪以后还会再给安吉拉唱歌，但你知道，如果他要拿出阿卡贝拉组合，他一定真的很喜欢她，是的，他全心全意。
I hope one of those guys was Broccoli Rob oh it had to have been Yeah. And Angela just looks at him and says she has to go clean up the party. And then we reveal that the whole bullpen has watched this. Yeah. Including Dwight.
我希望其中一个人是西兰花罗布，哦，那一定是。是的。安吉拉只是看着他说她得去清理派对现场。然后我们揭示了整个办公区都看了这一幕。是的。包括德怀特。
Yeah. And before we move on, Jenna, 38 minutes, 15 seconds. Prime elbow poof. Prime elbow poof of the sweater. I don't even understand this sweater, you guys. It was skinny at the top, then had a big floofy, poofy part right at the elbow, then skinny again down to the wrist. And it also had lace sewn in to the v-neck. Yeah, I mean, I think that we have to acknowledge that Andy serenaded Angela while she was wearing this terrible blouse.
是的。在我们继续之前，珍娜，38分15秒。极品肘部蓬松。毛衣的极品肘部蓬松。我甚至不理解这件毛衣，伙计们。它顶部很紧，然后在肘部有一个大大的、蓬松的部分，然后到手腕处又变紧了。而且V领上还缝了蕾丝。是的，我的意思是，我认为我们必须承认，安迪在安吉拉穿着这件糟糕的衬衫时为她献唱。
Yeah. No other man was going to hit on Angela today. Well, I'll tell you that because that blouse is a repellent. I think we have a callback to a flirty shade of beige here. Yes, very flirty shade of beige again, yes. Well, actually, it's like a Victorian shade of beige with the poofy sleeve, right? Yeah. The poofy elbow.
是的。今天没有其他男人会去搭讪安吉拉。好吧，我会告诉你，因为那件衬衫是驱虫剂。我想我们这里有一个对“调情的米色”的回应。是的，又是非常调情的米色，是的。好吧，其实，它就像是一种维多利亚时代的米色，带有蓬松的袖子，对吧？是的。蓬松的肘部。
Dwight ogles her in this flirty shade of beige and Andy sings to her. So clearly something was working. It's a shocker. Well, now we go into Michael's office and he and Dwight are just both miserable over this day. Yeah, they've had a day. And Michael says more than anything, he's bummed that he did not get to have authentic New York sushi. Not a thing. Yeah.
德怀特在这种调情的米色中盯着她看，安迪为她唱歌。所以显然有什么东西起作用了。真是令人震惊。好吧，现在我们进入迈克尔的办公室，他和德怀特对这一天都感到痛苦。是的，他们度过了糟糕的一天。迈克尔说，最重要的是，他很沮丧，因为他没能吃到正宗的纽约寿司。根本没那回事。是的。
New York has very good sushi. Yeah. But it is certainly, I don't think, the sushi capital. But whatever, Michael is really, really bummed. Yeah. And he says to Dwight, I think we should go to New York and get that sushi. You're driving. Dwight is so excited. He can't wait. He can't wait to drive all the way to New York to crash the tail end of this corporate party and get the leftover sushi that no one else wanted to eat. That's been sitting out for a while, for a long while, I just want to say. So that's what they do. They get there. They go into the party.
纽约有非常好的寿司。是的。但我认为它肯定不是寿司之都。但不管怎样，迈克尔真的非常沮丧。是的。他对德怀特说，我想我们应该去纽约吃那个寿司。你开车。德怀特太兴奋了。他等不及了。他等不及要一路开车去纽约，去闯入这个公司派对的尾声，吃掉没人想吃的剩寿司。那寿司已经放了一会儿了，放了很久了，我只想说。所以他们就是这么做的。他们到了那里。他们进入派对。
they get kicked out pretty much immediately there's no one there but they grab a plate of sushi and then they go and they sit on the hood of Dwight's car and guys this they did not go to New York to shoot this obviously this is a little
他们几乎立刻就被赶了出来，那里没有人，但他们抓了一盘寿司，然后他们去坐在德怀特的车盖上，伙计们，这个，他们显然没有去纽约拍这个，这是一个小
parking lot that they found in downtown L.A., I believe I recognized it because I think I've shot there they are just eating the sushi and they are making fun of Ryan and someone leaves the party and says to
停车场，他们在洛杉矶市中心找到的，我相信我认出来了，因为我想我在那里拍过戏，他们只是在吃寿司，他们在取笑瑞安，有人离开派对并对
Michael, hey, that was pretty awesome, you know, when you called Ryan out like that. And it is, it's like all he needed, right? Yeah. He feels seen and they're having sushi and they're in New York and now he can go home. And he sets the tray of sushi and soy sauce on someone else's car and they go home. It's pretty amazing. And then we have just a little tag at the end. We just see Ryan in full douche mode.
迈克尔说，嘿，那太棒了，你知道，当你那样当众揭穿瑞安的时候。就是这样，这正是他所需要的，对吧？是的。他感到被看见了，他们在吃寿司，他们在纽约，现在他可以回家了。他把寿司盘和酱油放在别人的车上，然后他们回家了。这真是太神奇了。然后我们在最后有一个小彩蛋。我们看到瑞安处于完全的混蛋模式。
winking at the camera from his New York party that's in full swing. Oh, yeah. So pleased with himself. Well, I don't know if you thought about it, but this scene had basically three couples in it, having intimate moments. We have Jim and Pam, dinner on the roof. We have Andy and Angela serenading and accounting. And we have Michael and Dwight having dinner in a parking lot. Yeah.
从他正在进行的纽约派对上对着镜头眨眼。哦，是的。对自己非常满意。好吧，我不知道你们有没有想过，但这一幕里基本上有三对情侣，有着亲密的时刻。我们有吉姆和帕姆，在屋顶吃晚餐。我们有安迪和安吉拉在会计部献唱。我们有迈克尔和德怀特在停车场吃晚餐。是的。
Very sweet. Very sweet. And we had one hostage, but we let him go. Well, guys, that was launch party part two. And a big thank you to Jen Salada and Kevin McHale and Steve Doucherer for all the behind the scenes details. Yeah, guys, thank you so much for always letting us reach out to get those details each week. We really appreciate it. And we're going to be doing it for like three more years. So don't get to tired of us. Everyone check your DMs if you've ever had anything to do with the office. Please check in. We'll be there. There's a good chance Jen and I are there saying, hey, what's
非常甜。非常甜。我们有一个人质，但我们放了他。好吧，伙计们，那是《发布会》第二部分。非常感谢简·萨拉达、凯文·麦克哈尔和史蒂夫·多彻提供所有的幕后细节。是的，伙计们，非常感谢你们总是让我们联系以获取每周的那些细节。我们真的很感激。而且我们还要再做三年左右。所以别对我们感到厌倦。如果你们曾经和《办公室》有任何关系，请检查你们的私信。请签到。我们会在那里的。简和我很有可能在那里说，嘿，怎么
up? All right, guys, we'll see you next week. Take care. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jirkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
了？好了，伙计们，我们下周见。保重。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。